>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mark Winek: Welcome
to the annual meeting
of the Potomac Technical
Processing Librarians.
My name is Mark Winek.
And I've had the pleasure of
serving as the PTPL Chair for 2015.
And, today marks our 91st
meeting as a group devoted
to the technical side of
supporting the informational needs
of school children, university
students, the legal profession,
religious communities, the military,
the marginalized, and
everyone in between.
And, before we get the
days proceedings underway,
I'll also get the thanks
out of the way.
And, I would like to express
my deepest debt of gratitude
to the 2015 PTPL Advisory Board.
If you're on the board, could
you please stand up just
so people can recognize you.
Thank you.
Not only have they made
each meeting a pleasure,
they've each provided
their unique talents
to make PTPL a stronger organization
in this year and for the future.
And, I'd especially like to
thank the Executive Committee,
Vice Chair Tiffany Wilson,
Past Chair Linda Geisler,
Secretary Sue Neilson,
and Treasurer Linda Wirth.
We've especially to
thanks Linda Geisler.
Linda returned to the PTPL
Advisor Board when we were in need
of an executive two years ago.
Not only has she provided
her services faithfully,
she used her good offices to insure
that we had a monthly meeting
place here in the Madison building
and took the lead on
coordinating the space
and catering required
for today's meeting.
And, I also want to
thank Bobby Reeves,
our webmaster who keeps the website
and the conference
registration running year
after year without any complaint.
And, Keri I hope that's reflected
on his annual review every year.
So, for your convenience, Wi-Fi is
provided by the Library of Congress.
The network name is locguest while
and you won't need a user name
and password but you will have to
consent to the terms and conditions.
Restrooms are located out the main
entrance of the Montpelier room
across from the elevators
down the hall on the right.
There's a scheduled 15 minute
break in the proceedings at 11am
and lunch will be served from
12:15 to 1:15 in this room
with vegetarian options available.
And, if you don't keep
to a vegetarian diet,
we ask that you insure
that there are plenty
of such options available
for those who do.
And finally, just for
the next few minutes,
there are signup sheets available
at the registration table,
the optional Library of Congress
tour immediately after the meeting.
And so, the tour is complementary
but the space is limited and we have
to provide the numbers to the
doses early so please make sure
and preregister if you
are interested in that.
So, without further
ado, it's my pleasure
to welcome our keynote
speaker Dorothea Salo.
Dorothea is a Faculty Associate
in the School of Library
and Information Studies at the
University of Wisconsin Madison.
At Madison, she teaches organization
of information, database design,
and surprising, and
surprisingly XML and linked data.
She has presented internationally
on linked data
and data curation,
among other topics.
Prior to her move to
Wisconsin, she spent two years
as a digital repository
services librarian
at George Mason University
in Fairfax.
And, please join me in
welcoming Dorothea Salo.
>> Dorothea Salo: Turn
this this way.
We're doing the usual switching
laptops today while we're.
While we're waiting, I,
actually, personally would
like to thank Linda, thank
Linda for hosting me.
It was very, very gracious
and I so appreciate it.
and, thank you, all of you,
for the wonderful welcome
I've had here today.
So, I am Dorothea Solo.
And, I am not nor have
I ever been a cataloger.
Though, I may be, I'm not sure, I
may be one of the last generation
of library school students
who's actually required
to take a cataloging course.
I don't know.
I just know we, at the iSchool,
AW Madison are doing one
of our periodic major
curricular revisions.
And, current odds are that we're
keeping the core organization
information course
because that's core.
We're just changing it to
deemphasize MARC cataloging a bit
in order to include more
material that's relevant
to non-MARC environment because
that's where an increasing number
of our students are going.
So, interesting times,
not that they're ever not.
So, curriculum revisions,
they are never fun.
They eat everybody's
time for months on end.
They always cause bureaucratic
hassles out the wazzoo.
For a while, you have to deal
with two different
incompatible curricula.
And remember, which are, which rules
apply to which student you're trying
to advise, next week's advising
week, so it's on my mind.
And, it's, it's a mess.
So, why do we do this to ourselves?
Right? Why do we bother if
it's such an awful hassle?
And, this is my answer.
[ Speaking foreign language ]
Because it must be done.
Just, in Latin it kind
of sounds cooler.
We at the iSchool cannot
just sit back
and do what we've always done just
because we've always
done it that way.
Not when the world that our
graduates are needing to fit
into is way different
from what it was
when we built the old curriculum.
And, it doesn't mean we did a
bad job on the old curriculum.
I don't think we did.
It's just that the world has
changed out from under it.
So, we have to change
the curriculum.
We don't have to enjoy it.
We just have to do it
because it must be done.
Not entirely coincidentally,
that's kind of how I feel
about the move away from MARC.
It feels, to me, like a lot of
library professionals spend,
at least, half a decade
on the question.
[ Speaking in foreign language ]
Or, why must it be done.
If you know this question
sounds really cool in Latin,
I have completely lost
patience with it.
Don't even tell me
nobody's asking this still,
I straight up heard it just
last May at the conference.
Totally still out there
floating in the water.
And, if you like water, here's
some nice water, nice harbor,
really pretty, love
the little lighthouse.
But, the thing that isn't
in this pretty picture
of a pretty harbor is a ship
because the why can't we
use MARC ship has sailed.
It has sailed.
Not even having the why do we
have to change discussion today.
I don't see the point.
That ship has sailed.
I mean, and that's just
program planner as it happens
for the IT division of the
Special Libraries Association.
And, I was talking to SLA's
technical services planner,
Betty Landesman, maybe
some of you know her.
She's local to this area.
Was talking to her about
a linked data session.
She rolled her eyes at me and she
said can we please not, right,
do yet another intro to linked
data and why it's better than MARC?
Can we not?
I've seen a ton of hose
and they don't help.
Okay then.
If I've got catalogers
yelling at me not to do this,
I'm going to try not to do it.
Because, really, the answer
is exactly the same as it is
for our curriculum
revisions at the iSchool.
[ Foreign language spoken ]
Because it must be done.
I do want to mention, though,
because I come at technical services
from an XML and metadata background
rather than a MARC background.
But, it isn't just MARC cataloging
that the bell is tolling for here.
There's zero chance that XML
based metadata practice is going
to stay the way it is
today, not going to happen.
I already see it changing.
Not even sure XML is going to stay
alive as a pure metadata format
as opposed to uses like TEI for the
visual humanities, EAD for archives
where you're dealing with narrative
type documents that are intended
for mostly for human beings,
that's where XML really shines.
I think those will survive.
But, XML for metadata, not sure.
And, you know, I'm
actually okay with that.
I'm okay with XML's decline
as a metadata serialization,
I never liked my nice clean elegant
document standard getting worked
over by the data engineers anyway.
Don't even talk to me
about an XML schema.
Maybe now I can have
XML back for documents,
the way it's supposed to be.
Now, I'm actually much more
interested in this question.
[ Speaking in foreign language ]
What actually is it
that must be done?
What do we have to do to our
catalog data and our other metadata
so that it works in this world
where so much has changed
about how people find information?
I like this question
because it's pragmatic.
I like this question because
it's intriguingly complicated.
I like it because it's
nervy in all the best ways.
I like it because I'm an
inveterate fiddler with things,
and there's just great
huge masses of MARC
and XML right there
waiting to be filled with.
And, it's just another of these
questions that we got to work
on or we just stay stuck.
Right? And, I don't think it's
enough to just say well what we have
to do is we have to migrate our
data from MARC and mods and mets
and the various cores,
Dublin core, Darwin core,
VRA core, PB core, all the cores.
We have to migrate all that
to link data then we're done.
That's skipping all the steps.
Right? that's an underpants
gnomes approach, you know,
migrate all the things to link
data, step two question mark,
question mark, question
mark, step three profit not.
That's not enough.
That's like saying we
have to pick up some rocks
and then we'll turn them
into a giant mosaic.
Not enough information there.
What's the mosaic design
going to be?
Where's the mosaic
going to be built?
Where do we find the right colored
rocks and how do we cut them
up if they're too big or
they're not the right shape?
How do we glue all the rocks down?
What happens if somebody glues
down a rock in the wrong place?
What if there's an earthquake?
So yeah, we've got to work on some
process here, I think, for mosaics
and certainly for our
data and metadata as well.
And the other reason I don't
think it's quite enough
to say what we have to do is
migrate everything to link data is
that it assumes without proof
that link data is the ultimate
destination for all of our stuff.
Which yeah, now it's
the horse to bet on,
I'm certainly not denying that.
But, I think link data gets
used as a stocking horse,
sometimes a little
bit of a scapegoat.
It's link data's fault we
have to change away from MARC.
It's link data's fault all of these
changes are happening to begin with.
If it weren't for link data
supposedly being the new hotness,
we could just stay the way we
are and everything would be fine.
And, I don't actually
think that's true.
If link data didn't
exist, and believe you me,
there are times I would love to
wipe RDF off the face of the earth,
if there were not link data,
we'd still have to make changes
in how we collect and organize
our catalog data and our metadata.
And, we have to make those
changes for the same reason
that we're changing our
curriculum at the iSchool.
The world is just plain changed
out from under the old ways.
And, that didn't happen
when the Library of Congress
or the British Library or
the National Library of Spain
or the wonderful folks at
Oslo, that didn't happen
when they announced
their link data plans.
The changes happened a
lot earlier than that.
They happened, these changes, when
paper cards gave way to the web
as the main way the patrons
interact with library catalogs
and with digital collections.
And, yeah, yeah, if you're,
I know there are people
who are medievalists in here.
So, I cheated, the left hand
picture there is not actually paper,
it's papyrus.
But no, that's when it happened.
And, I mean, it's not
that we didn't notice.
Of course we noticed.
How could you not?
It's just taken a while
for us to figure
out what we need to do about it.
Oops, which I don't know how to
say that in Latin, but, oops.
I think we maybe waited
longer than we should have.
But that's, you know, that's
water under the bridge now.
Leads me right back here.
[ Foreign language spoken ]
What do we have to do now
that the work that we do has
to play nicely with computers?
And, not just computers.
I mean, MARC was designed through
computers, but networked computers,
computers that can
talk to one another
because the network really
does kind of change the game.
We're going to start
with my students,
when I teach our core organization
information course, I start here.
[ Foreign language spoken ]
Which basically means
computers aren't real bright.
I mean that.
Computers are not all that
bright, I tell my students.
You are way smarter than a computer.
And, I say this for
a lot of reasons.
One reason is knocking
computers off pedestals,
not actually literally knocking
computers off pedestals, though,
hey that would be kind of cool.
But, you know, what I mean.
Right? A lot of my students
come into the iSchool thinking
that computers are small gods.
They're magical, they're capricious,
they're inscrutable, they're liable
to mess you up like Diana's about
to mess up that antelope there.
And, I'm saying, I have
to get them to not think
that because the more
they understand
about how computers do work,
the better off they are
and the better off we all are.
But, actually, the main reason
that the notion the computers
aren't real bright is relevant
to this talk today is that,
from our point of view
as literate human beings,
computers are not too bright
in some very specific and
fairly easy to understand ways.
And, those ways tell us, actually,
pretty clearly what our catalog
metadata and other data have to look
like if we want computers
to work effectively with it.
And, really, this is no different
from how the shape and size
of catalog cards and
the standard size
of type written lettering shaped
how the MARC record had to look.
The technology that you have
available in the card catalog,
totally technology, don't let
anybody tell you it isn't,
the technologies available to you
shaped how it makes the most sense
to do things because different
technologies are good and bad
at different things and need
different things to function best.
That's basic design theory.
If you haven't read Donald
Norman's Design of Everyday Things
and a couple of its sequels
already, please read them.
Brilliant stuff that will,
it will explode your brain
in all the best ways.
So, the first thing to remember
about computers and I hear,
I see some people already smiling,
they know where I'm going with this.
The first things to remember about
computers is the text, right,
the ordinary stuff that we write
every day for other people to read,
the text that we literate human
beings read and comprehend so fast
so easily so accurately that we
hardly have to think about it.
It is all Greek to a computer.
Right. You knew that cliche
was showing up at some point.
How could I not?
Computers can't read.
They are functionally illiterate.
If anybody in this room has a
kindergarten age child at home,
your kindergartener reads
and comprehends text immensely
better than a computer can.
So, my head, one step toward
coping with illiterate computers,
is dealing with our
addiction to textual notes.
By way of example, I took these
MARC 504s straight from the Library
of Congress' MARC documentation.
And, thanks for that, by the way.
If anybody here's is in
anyway responsible for it,
it is super helpful in my classroom.
But, for example, if a
patron question that we would
like our catalogs to be able to
answer is hey I'm new to this topic,
can I get a recent book with
a good bibliography please.
Right. Perfectly reasonable
question.
These notes, being free text means
that our catalogs can't
actually come up with an answer.
Because, to get to an answer
means filtering a list of books
by whether they have
a bibliography or not.
And, to do that with MARC notes,
the computer has to read the text.
And, it's got to understand that
bibliography and bibliographies
and bibliographical and literature
cited and sources and maybe whatever
that Romanized Russian is.
I'm not even sure I
didn't look it up.
It's got to figure out that this
all means yes there is some kind
of bibliography in this book.
And no, a computer can't just
look for the existence of a 504.
That's not enough because 540s
don't just note down bibliographies,
they also note down indexes and
maybe some other information.
So, straight up, the computer is not
bright enough to figure this out.
It can't read, much less read
all the languages that we end
up transcribing stuff in especially
here at the Library of Congress.
Right? Much less, comprehend
what it's reading.
And, that makes a lot of the stuff
in our mark records a lot less
useful to patrons than it could be.
Computers get yes or no.
Yes or no, on or off, this they get.
They're real good at that.
Checkboxes are candy to computers.
Computers love checkboxes.
So, for any conceivable criterion
that we want our patrons to be able
to search on or filter their
results on, we pretty much got
to quit recording it in text and
make it a checkbox or, you know,
radio buttons, if there's more
than two options that also works.
If you get the sense
from this that I really
like MARC fixed fields,
you're totally right.
Though, honestly, that's your thing.
That's a little weird.
If a lot more of MARC had been
expressed in fixed fields instead
of free text, we'd be in a much,
much better situation right now.
Now, let's say for a moment, let's
pretend that the titanic arguments
that we in the profession
are going to have to have
about when a book is said
to have a bibliography
and what actually counts as an
index, let's say we've done that
and we've drawn the
best line we know how.
We're still going to have to deal
with this giant horrible mass
of free text that's hanging out in
our 504s in our catalogs right now
because computers aren't
bright enough to understand it.
[ Foreign language spoken ]
It's got to be done.
And, I don't want to get
down to the weeds on this.
Actually I'd love to
if we had the time
because this is exactly the
kind of problem I salivate over.
I'm a giant nerd though
and not everybody is.
So, I just want to say this
class of problem can be solved
for the great mass of our
records without hand editing.
And, of course, it's got to be
because there ain't enough
staff time in the universe
to check all those checkboxes.
And, it's a thing that's got to
be done for every characteristic
in our free text notes
that we want users,
patrons to be able to
filter or search on.
Another serious and ugly free text
problem we have in our records has
to do with places where our
content standards don't force us
to be consistent about how we record
information, you know, what as,
we're cool, just type something.
It's fine.
And, on catalog cards, this
inconsistency didn't matter.
Right. Because, the information
was only ever going to be looked
at by a human being who doesn't
need the consistency to figure
out what's going on,
on the individual card.
We're literate humans.
We're smart.
We can figure this stuff out.
Computers are astoundingly
literal minded, right.
You can take some text, add a
space to it, and all the sudden,
to the computer, it's
a different thing.
Just a space, right?
A human being wouldn't
even be able to see it.
But, to the computer, new thing.
Once again, not just a
MARC thing, consistency
and Dublin core metadata,
don't make me laugh.
I actually am more likely to cry.
It's really that how dare.
And, I once got an
entire published article,
cataloging classification
quarterly, you can look it up.
Out of one poor soul in the
Institutional Repository
that was running at the
time, the poor guy had stuff
under eight slightly different
spellings of his name, eight.
Just terrible.
And yeah, I fixed it as soon
as I had the screenshot I made
through the article, I wasn't
just going to leave it like that.
But, it goes to show, doesn't it?
And I want to call out two Dublin
core things specifically noting
that you're going to find these
problems a lot more places
than Dublin core.
Dates, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh dates.
Dates are really important
to information seekers.
So, it's really important that
we record them consistently
such that a computer can reasonably
intelligently filter based on them.
And, oh boy, we're not there yet.
We're not even close to there.
Dublin core, MARC,
totally doesn't matter.
The people who try to make not too
bright computers work are tearing
out their hair about
the way we do dates.
And, we've got to fix this.
[ Foreign Language spoken ]
It's got to be done.
As for write statements, this
is another one that comes
from the digital collection
side more than the catalog side.
It's important because
the people who come
to our digital collections often
want to use them in particular ways
and they want to know
if they're allowed to.
We have to be clear about what
our patrons are allowed to do.
And, to do that, our search
engines have to be able to tell
which users can do
what with which items.
And, that's all free text now
and it's a complete disaster.
Europeana and Digital Public Library
of America are working on this,
thankfully, bringing a little bit
of reason, I hope, to this chaos.
I don't not envy them
that job one big.
Copyright's bad enough, free
text only makes it worse.
So, an example of the difficulties
with free text that I use
in class a lot is from Library
software developer Bill Dueber
who took a close look at what was
after the ISBN in the 020 field
in the catalog that
he was working with.
And wow, it's horrific.
Just the top 20 responses
over there on the left,
you can completely
see the inconsistency.
And the more you drill down on the
right he took a look at anything
that was kind of sort of
hardback and he got all those.
Yeah. The more you drill
down, the worse it gets.
So yeah. Our catalogs can't answer
the very simple question yo this
book print or electronic or both?
At least not based on the 020.
And yeah, I know RDA fixes this
and yay that's a good
thing to have fixed.
Bottom line though, a lot
of our catalog data is just
hopelessly internally inconsistent.
And, sometimes that's material for
patrons and sometimes it isn't.
I'm not saying that
this is the top thing
that we've got to fix
in our catalogs.
I don't actually know what that is.
That, that knowledge, that
expertise is with you.
But, when it is material,
right, this is my call
to control all the things, all
of them, anything that's useful,
material to patrons, in a record
that is not actually
transcribed off the item,
needs a controlled
vocabulary, or, you know,
other appropriate standardized
expression.
You can't do a controlled
vocabulary for date,
you just have to be really clear
about how they're written
down, I can't with this.
what? What even is this?
And computers is even worse.
What is just type something
is not okay in 2015.
Transcribe it or control it.
There is no third option.
[ Foreign language spoken ]
And, since I've used
to the word transcribe,
let me just say this thing where
we intentionally transcribe typos,
and other errors in records
and information that's material
to a patron searching a browsing,
can we, can we not please?
Can we not do that because
computers won't know.
Computers will happily operate
on the wrong information
not knowing that it's wrong.
So, we got to stop
propagating mistakes.
Consider it a service to publishers.
Poor guys, as well as our poor
patrons that done the 020 field
for another reason that
has nothing really to do
with cataloging practices
and more to do with ISBN's.
Now, I can see my org of
info students with this.
I can't fool you.
I want you to know I know this.
I can't fool you with this question
is the ISBN a good book identifier?
And, we all know it's not.
We know that tons of
books don't have ISBN's.
We know that ISBN's accidentally
and intentionally get reused.
We know that it's not totally clear
what a book even is in ISBN land.
It's kind of an addition
but not really.
It's kind of a format
question but not really.
It's all very, very confusing.
Perhaps, predictably, it
confuses computers too.
Because, computers
are so little minded,
they need to be really super
unambiguous when talking
about what kind of
thing something is.
They have to have a really
super clear definition.
This is a book.
This is a print book.
This is an eBook, you
know, whatever.
If you and the computer have a
different definition, different idea
in your head about what a book
is, well the computer is going
to do wild random unexpected
and unpredictable things
from your point of view.
And, you know, the computer is happy
to use whatever definition
we come up with.
It doesn't care.
But, in spite of Ferber and
sometimes it must be said
because of it, we don't really
have clear definitions here
that we can operationalize in
our systems that don't lead us
into logical contradictions
or really bad edge cases.
And, we kind of need that.
So, that's one thing.
We got to figure out what
exactly we're talking
about when we say things like book
and eBook and hardback and so on.
So, we can explain the distinctions
clearly to the computer.
And, if this reminds you of
Susan Briet trying to explain
when an antelope is a
document, and when it isn't.
I'm right there with you.
It's totally going to be weird and
sometimes theoretically like that.
And I have to say, this mosaic is
kind of like my personal head cannon
for this is how Susan Briet looks
to me now, you know, whatever works.
And then, once we've figured out the
kinds of things that we're talking
about in our, in our universe,
we have to be able to point.
And, excuse me for being rude,
but, be able to point clearly
and unambiguously at every single
example of those things that we,
collectively, as a
society, I will say,
that we have because that makes
it easier to pull the information
about these things that
we, collectively, have.
The network can work
for us if we let it.
But, to let the network work, the
network needs a common way to point
at things and understand
what's being pointed to.
And, for a computer, that
means an identifier that,
unlike an authority string,
can never ever change.
Computers get very
confused by change,
even more confused
than the rest of us.
And, for a network computer,
that means an identifier
that's unique not just
in your organization, your library.
So, your call number, bar code
number, that's not going to work.
It's got to be unique worldwide.
So, that means another thing.
It can't be language dependent.
Because, you know, we've tried
already collating our records
by fuzzy matching and
trying to deduplicate,
that's how Metasearch worked.
But, we pretty much, all know
that Metasearch never
worked all that well.
Computers are not bright enough
to fuzzy match well all the time.
And, catalog data and typical
metadata, they're sparse enough
that they're not good candidates,
there's not enough there
for a computer to fuzzy
match anyway.
We're still going to have to
use this just to get started
because it's what we've got.
We don't have anything better.
But, for some stuff,
for some catalogs,
the identifier thing is
going to be a long haul.
So, that means we've got to have
unique identifiers for our stuff
that are way more reliable
than ISBN's.
And, if you know the link data
world at all, you already know
that the scheme that's been settled
on for these is URI's which 99 times
out of 100 look like URL's.
And, the reasoning there
is we already know how
to make URL's global unique
because we already do that
or the web wouldn't work.
That's all it is.
It's just keeping the
computers from getting confused.
And so, another problem we
have to solve, if we're going
to take advantage of the
network, is taking identifiers
and quasi identifiers that we've
been using for things like ISBN's
like authority strings
and matching them
up with URI's URL's that's been
established for those things,
not going down in the weeds here not
even the seaweeds with the dolphins.
But, I do want you to
know, if you don't already,
the nerd word for this
process is reconciliation.
Nice word.
And, it can be partially automated
if you know your source data well
as catalogers tend to do.
And, the win here is that once
you have a URI for something,
you can go out in the
network and ask a whole bunch
of trustworthy sources,
hey, what do you know
about this thing and
get back answers.
To me, that's what we now think of
as copy cataloging is going to work.
You ask tiny little questions
of very reliable sources,
get tiny little answers
back, and you build them
up into your search engines and
your facets and your browsing tools,
and all the other user
interface chrome
that we're already familiar with.
And, it won't have
to be done by hand.
If you tell a computer
every time a feed you a URI
for a book we just bought, ask this
question of that source in this way
and store the answer there.
And, it will do that reliably and
consistently every single time.
And, I certainly believe this will
be a better solution to what I think
of capitalized as the
problem of vendor records.
You're familiar with this problem.
I don't have to elaborate.
What I'm saying is the problem
of vendor records is nine times
out of ten a problem of vendors
struggling not only with ACR2
and MARC which are hard
enough, but with MARC practices
that are inconsistent across
libraries to begin with.
It'll be a lot easier for us
and for vendors if, instead,
our computers are asking
their computers a lot
of little tiny questions
with little tiny answers.
I'll at least say one last
thing about the 020 okay.
ISBN's not unique.
The field includes
inconsistent format information,
yeah, yeah, we got that.
Here's my question.
What the ever living heck
is format information doing
in an ISBN field to begin with?
But, much less information about
volumes of much less information
about volumes and multivolume
series.
And, if it does have to
be there, and, I know,
I actually do know why it's there,
can't it at least be
in a separate subfield?
What is this business
with the parentheses?
I'm showing a mosaic
detail here for a reason.
You can see all the little
tiny individual rock bits
and you can see how very carefully
they're placed and that none
of them overlap anywhere.
But that's what our catalog data
and metadata need to look like,
no overlaps, nothing just
jammed together willy-nilly,
everything in little tiny
bits and each tiny bit
in its own singular place
very carefully set apart
from the other tiny bits.
It's called granularity,
sometimes atomicity,
if you're a relational database
nerd and computers love it.
See, this is the thing
about computers.
Computers are really,
really good at building
up whole mosaics from
little tiny pieces.
They're good at that.
What they're critically
bad at is taking a whole
and breaking it down into parts.
We have to do that for them.
And, as we saw with the
020 field, we often don't.
Or, if we do, we do it in ways
that the computer finds
confusing or inconsistent.
So, I grabbed a couple of examples
from IFLA's ISBD supplement.
And, again, if anybody
here from IFLA,
thank you for this,
classroom lifesaver.
Just to show the difficulties,
think like a computer for a second.
There's a whole lot of
punctuation all up in here.
And, it's not at all obvious,
even to me, and I'm a human being,
what all of it means, what's
being set off by it or even
if it means anything at all.
I mean, just the physical
description, the globe there,
tell me what a period
or a dot means there.
What is space globe space colon
space call dot coma space plastic
space semicolon space 30 cm space
parentheses IM dot parentheses.
Okay. As a human being, I can figure
out that the dots there are
calling out abbreviations.
Right because I'm a human
being I'm smart that way.
Can I just tell the
computer now to assume
that a dot always mean
an abbreviation?
Of course I can't.
Because that's not what it
means in the other fields.
And, can anybody tell
me why, in the last area
of the globe description everything
except the final sentence has a dot
at the end?
It's enough to make a
programmer cry into her beer.
Wisconsin, beer's a thing.
I love the area labels
off here for legibility.
But, I just want to point out, we
actually have two competing sets
of delimiters happening here.
The areas which are set off
delimited by white space and what's
in each individual area, which
is funky punctuation city, and,
when you add that to MARC, we get
a whole other set of delimiters
in the form fields,
subfields, indicators.
I respect my colleagues
who teach cataloging.
Well, I could never do it.
I cut my teeth on XML where
delimiters are totally cut and dry.
The validator will tell
you if you screw them up.
This mismatch completely
bewildering to me.
Bottom example there,
anybody see an error?
I mean, I think there's an error.
It's kind of hard to tell.
But, that very bottom
line, if that's supposed
to be an m dash before the
word canyon, it actually isn't.
Human being, no big deal, to
a computer, very big deal.
Just goes to show we can't even
be sure documentation is right.
So, anybody who works with XML
now is twitching [inaudible].
Sorry about that.
But, it illustrates an
important point about delimiters.
A lot of my students find learning
markup HTML XML really frustrating
because they've never had to be 100%
consistent about delimiters before.
So, they make tiny little mistakes
like leaving off an angle bracket,
and they haven't learned to
look for those mistakes yet.
They don't understand
what the validator,
which notices the mistakes,
is trying to tell them.
It's really frustrating for them.
So, what I tell them
is suck it up and deal.
Okay, no, I'm not actually
that evil about it.
I'm pretty careful to point
out the kinds of errors
that beginners usually
make and I tell them
that everyone makes those
errors even really skilled
and experienced people.
And, it's okay, the whole point
of validator is to
help us get it right.
Well, fundamentally, yeah,
they got to learn to deal.
And, they don't like
that but too bad.
[ Foreign language spoken ]
It must be done.
Don't confuse the computer.
Reliable and consistent delimiter
use is how we avoid confusing
the computer.
Delimit in just one way, delimit
clearly, delimit unambiguously.
And, you know, I have
to show this thing
that absolutely broke my heart.
I was digging in the history
of MARC ISBD internationally,
it was just a rabbit
hole I fell down.
And, it turns out, a while back,
the Germans were totally bent
on killing ISBD punctuation
out of the MARC record relying
on MARC delimiters only.
Which, from the point of view
2015 totally would've been the
right decision.
But, how could they know English
speaking MARC went the ISBD
direction instead.
And, 20/20 hindsight,
what can you do?
So, what is it that
we got to do now?
[ Foreign language spoken ]
We got to get a handle
on our free text issues.
When we're saying the
same thing more than once,
we need to say it the
same way every time.
We need to atomize our data, make it
as granular as it can possibly be.
The delimiter thing,
sometimes we have too many
and sometimes we don't have enough.
And, it would be nice to
find a happy medium there.
And, when we can identify
something as well as labeling it
for our patrons, we should
because identifiers are
labels for computers.
Identifiers make network
computers happy and useful.
And, just to reiterate,
we don't have
to do these things
because link data.
We have to do these things
because relational databases,
because search engines, because
faceted browsing, because internet,
because web, basically, because
not too bright computers.
No secret.
Cards on the table here.
If we do do these things, we'll be
a whole lot closer to link data.
So, it's not like I'm ignoring that.
Not at all.
I'm just saying link data is
not all that this is about.
So, that's great.
Those who are in this room
that are a bit younger,
you've got jobs for life here.
I tell my students, this is
your career, this migration,
this transition is what you'll
be spending your career on.
Plenty of work.
So, how do we actually
do it exactly?
Good question to have an answer to.
By hand, one record at
a time, not the answer.
It can't be.
We've got too many records.
I mean, yeah, there's still
going to be weird outliers
that we end up fixing by hand.
There always are.
Oh boy I could tell you stories.
I'm sure you could
tell me stories too.
But, we need to throw computers
at fixing the easier problems
and limit the hand work
to those weird outliers.
We've just go too much data
to do it any other way.
And, because we live with networked
computers, I'm not totally sure
that doing it one organization
at a time is quite the way
either because, in my head,
and I lived this with institutional
repositories, it kind of means
that we're all solving the same
problems redundantly in parallel
and we don't need to
do that, necessarily.
It costs too much and it's
going to take too long.
But, the truth is, we collectively
don't yet have the knowhow
that we need to collaborate on this.
Most computer programmers
don't have the depth of MARC
and the ACR2 knowledge that
they need to fix these problems.
And, most catalogers, I won't say
most, but, many catalogers don't
yet know how to work with a
great mass of records as opposed
to editing one record at a time.
So, this particular problem,
this collaboration problem.
[ Foreign language spoken ]
It is solved by learning.
Catalogers, developers, we've
all got some learning to do.
And I mean, I would say that.
Right? I'm a teacher.
But, I am a teacher
because I believe this.
It is solved by learning.
Managers in the room,
supervisors, please,
give your people time
and space to learn.
Do not make me yell at you
about this because I will.
Straight up, your cataloging
backlog or that new tech thing
that your developers are currently
working on is far less important
than this strategic
preparation for what's coming
down the pipeline at you.
By all means, hold your people
accountable for actually learning.
I'm in favor of that.
Some people will say they want to
learn and then complain endlessly
about it, I can tell you stories
and you can probably
tell me stories too.
Hold them accountable
but let them learn.
Help them learn.
Learn yourself.
It won't kill you.
It might make you stronger.
Here's some tools that I think are
well worth adding to your tool kit,
if they're not there already because
they're designed to fix stuff
in lots of records at once
rather than or possibly
in addition to one record at a time.
I've ordered them by the order
in which I would recommend
that a cataloger learn them.
And, the last half,
you may not even need.
I mentioned these because
there's situation
where they're genuinely
going to be useful.
Start with MARC edit,
it's the workhorse.
It's got an increasing number
of really good batch
record editing tools.
I don't know that I need
to say anything about that.
Most of you in this
room probably already,
at least, have heard of this tool.
Next, who I recommend
is open refine.
You may see it called
Google Refine as well.
There's a variant on open refine
that's specifically designed
for getting to and from link data.
It's called log refine for
linked open data refine.
And, you have to install
it anyway, so,
you might as well install the one
that's ready for linked data anyway.
Regular expressions are kind of the
first nerdy thing I ever learned.
So, I'm kind of over fond of them.
Regular expressions are
search and replace tools
that do pattern matching in very,
very nifty and sophisticated ways.
So, if you're interesting in
learning regular expressions,
I found this wonderful site
and I actually have my
students using it now.
It makes me very happy.
regex1.com series, a very,
very nicely presented
tutorials getting you used
to regular expressions,
strongly, strongly recommend it.
So, last three.
If you have to extract data from
relational database or put data back
into a relational data base.
Structured Query Language,
SQL, is the language
that you learn to do that with.
We teach a lot of it
in this semester.
It's not, you know, if you
can handle MARC and ACR2,
you can totally handle SQL.
If you have a lot of XML around,
there is a little language,
if you will, that's designed to take
XML and turn it into other stuff,
including linked data,
if that's your thing.
It's called XSLT.
The learning curve there is steep.
I recommend looking at other
people's code to get started.
But, I actually love
XSLT, I'm weird that way.
Last thing, this is
relatively new and changing
and I really don't
recommend starting here
because here there'll be yaks.
And, if you've heard the phrase
yak shaving from your developers,
yak shaving is all the
really annoying work you have
to do before you can actually do
the work that solves your problem.
Right? So, installing
Katmandu in fixed,
there's a lot of yak shaving
there, I will warn you.
But, Katmandu in fixed
come out of France.
Fix is a little language aimed at
batch editing metadata, really,
really interesting little project.
I think it will get easier to use.
And, therefore, I think it's
worth keeping an eye on even
if you don't dive into
it right this second.
So, how should you learn and what
should you do with what you learn?
In my head, those questions
are intimately entwined.
In some circles, I'm known
for the phrase beating things
with rocks until they work.
And, if you use rocks for mosaics,
this probably won't
work, they're too small.
But, you get the idea.
I think plain or mucking
around and breaking things
and fixing them once you break them
is the best way to learn new tools.
It's certainly how I do it.
And, it's certainly how I
kind of dump my students
in the deep end and have them do it.
Pick something to so with
the tool, then do it.
And, if a few rocks get beaten
on along the way, it's all good.
What should you pick to
do with the tools exactly?
Well, try cleaning
up your catalog data.
Right? Fix your 020's
with MARC edit.
See if you can at least make
those format notes a little
more consistent.
Export your data to something
open refine can read, it's doable.
I know catalogers who have done it.
See if you can cluster your 504s
such that you can start to try
and answer the question which
books have bibliographies
which books have indexes.
Try fixing your dates,
have fun with that.
All kinds of fun and interesting
problems you'll run into with dates
and have to come up
with a way to solve.
But, boy will you learn
the tool that way.
You know your catalogs
a lot better than I do.
Right? You know where
the worst problems are.
You know the bits of data you had
that you wish the computers
understood
so that they could answer
patron questions better.
so, you know where the most
important problems to fix are.
And, that's crucial knowledge.
So, learn the tools
by fixing the problems
that you already know are there.
So, experts to watch.
[ Foreign language spoken ]
Christina Harlow doing
fabulous work, amazing work.
Just published an article
on Katmandu
and Fix in the Code4Lib Journal.
Again, I don't recommend that
you dive into that right away.
But, if you want to see
what real people are doing,
Christina's one to watch.
Karen Coyle of course, Diane
Hillman, of course, Owen Stephens,
Owen's a Brit doing very
interesting things just playing
around with data to
see what he can do.
He's got a nice blog
at ostephens.com.
I rip him off constantly for
stuff for my linked data class.
And, of course, OCLC research
because they're doing this at scale,
they have to and learning very
interesting thing thereby.
Person I would particularly watch
is Tom Hickey who has a blog,
I meant to look it
up and then I didn't.
But, yes, you can find him online.
So, you got a lot of work to do.
And, we know it's got to be done.
So, let's jump in there and do it.
Thank you very much.
And, I'm happy to take
questions if you have them.
>> Mark Winek: Thank
you so much Dorothea.
>> Dorothea Salo: Oh you're welcome.
>> Mark Winek: We do
have microphones.
And, we would ask that you raise
your hand if you have a question
and so that other people
can hear your question.
>> Dorothea Salo: Mark, there's
one way in the back there.
>> Frank Newton: I'm Frank Newton.
I am.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hi Frank.
>> Frank Newton: I am, I wanted
to ask you whether
computers contain hypotheses?
And, the reason I'm asking
is because it seems to me
that that's what human
beings do with punctuation.
>> Dorothea Salo: Yes.
>> Frank Newton: I'm a
huge fan of punctuation.
And, I think the reason that MARC
records have a lot of punctuation
in them is because
citation standards like MLA
and APA have a lot of
punctuation in them.
And, I think that catalog
cards began
as an elaboration of
a citation format.
>> Dorothea Salo: I agree.
>> Frank Newton: And, I don't
mean to say that people,
while people were developing card
catalogs and what information
and how they would format it
on card catalogs they were
constantly saying we want
to make this like citation format.
I just think that that
was constantly in the back
of their minds and not necessarily,
not necessarily articulated a lot.
So, lots of punctuation, but, by
and large, mostly, it seems to me,
periods do not have an
infinite number of meanings.
They have certain meanings
that have high probabilities.
And, one of them is the one you
mentioned about abbreviations.
So, suppose you have a globe and
you have metadata for a globe
and in parentheses
you have DIAM., then,
what I would like to the computer
to do is to entertain the hypothesis
that that period is there because
there's a longer word that begins
with DIAM that has
to do with globes.
And, that's the way I believe
a human being would operate.
>> Dorothea Salo: Yep.
>> Frank Newton: And, and we
go to our mental dictionaries
and we find the word diameter.
And, I don't know how
exactly we do that.
But, I don't completely feel
that that's beyond the realm
of programing to figure out how we
connect DIAM with the word diameter.
So, and, that's another, in addition
to saying that I like punctuation,
I also wanted to say that
I think sometimes we assume
that things are un-programmable
when, in fact, they're perfectly,
they're really not
that hard to program.
And, I would, I wish, I'm
not a programmer at all.
But, I wish that somebody
would program computers
to use the singular and plural
form of nouns accurately.
So, I don't it when a computer says
to me one books because I know that,
after one, there's, you're supposed
to leave off the S
at the end of books.
And, I don't see why computers
couldn't be programmed
to understand that too.
And.
>> Dorothea Salo: The
question is, how much money
and programmer time are you going
to spend asking a computer to act
like a human being when
computers can't really do that?
And, we have thrown an awful lot
of money, an awful lot of time
and a lot of vendors and a
lot of developers asking them
to do this impossible thing because,
no, computers don't get hypotheses.
It's yes or no.
Right. That's what they get.
And so, what you end up doing,
and the singular plural problem
is relatively easy to solve.
That's an easy one.
Anybody know about Inera?
I can't remember where
they're based now.
They're a service software
company for publishers.
And, the reason they exist and
the reason they make their money,
and they're a very
profitable corporation,
is that they have written
immense amounts
of computer code just
to parse citations.
Right? That's a multimillion
dollar industry
because computers are so bad at it.
Right. So yeah, we can
solve these problems.
Don't we have better
problems to solve?
I guess is where I'm at on that.
More questions?
>> Christine Delany: My
name is Christine Delany
from American University Library.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hi Christine.
>> Christine Delany: Hi.
And, my question has to
do with authority work.
>> Dorothea Salo: Yeah.
>> Christine Delany: I've heard
some received some mixed information
about whether or not, in
the linked data world,
authority work will be
necessary to perform.
We won't need authority
records etcetera.
Can you say a few words about
your thoughts about authority,
authority work and authority
records in a linked data world?
>> Dorothea Salo: I think there's
going to be gigantically more of it.
When I say control all the things,
that to me means we have
authorities and more of them.
We have more controlled
vocabularies.
So, authority worked in the
linked data world is going
to be focused a little less on
figuring out the labels and more on,
okay, we've slapped an identifier
on this person who just wrote a book
for the first time or on this
place that just became a place.
And the authority, the authority
work becomes what else do we know
that we can attach
to this identifier?
We know the name for the place.
We know the time it was established.
We know where else it is in
the universe, things like that.
So, authority work will
change a little bit,
the emphasis is going to change.
But, yeah, we still got to do it.
The fun thing is, though, that we
don't have to do it individually
and in parallel because that's
what the network buys us.
As soon as one person
knows something interesting
about a person represented by
a URL, they tell the world.
And now, nobody else has to
gather that piece of information
because it's out there
and we can ask for it.
So yes, definitely
still authority work
but it will be networked
authority work.
>> So, I had a question about
back editing subject headings.
>> Dorothea Salo: Yeah.
>> Because.
>> Dorothea Salo: Scary
stuff sometimes.
>> Because a lot, I
mean, you were talking
about how other data's inconsistent.
But, as a cataloger,
I've actually found
that subject headings are the
most inconsistent because there's
so many terms that can be used
for like one piece of information.
And, there's only so many
that can be put in a record
without overwhelming a record.
>> Dorothea Salo: Right.
>> So, I was wondering if, if
there's a bunch of similar records,
if an institution can sort
of like batch edit those?
>> Dorothea Salo: I hope so
because we're going to have to do
that a lot, well, not a lot.
I don't actually know how much.
Let me be clear about this.
A lot of this problem arises
because subject terminology
does change over time.
And, sometimes we have time
to fix it in our records
and sometimes we kind of don't.
So, that's just, you know,
acute time poverty is one reason
that subject headings
get into such a state.
So, there's some interesting
things that can happen
with subject headings
in a linked data world.
And, let me see how
I want to frame this.
One of them is that, I think,
we, I think there are better ways
to handle pre-coordination and
presenting pre-coordination
to patrons than we currently have.
So, I think that, actually, once we
do the work, will be a big benefit.
Some of it is actually using a
subject heading to follow our nose
and not just through
library collections
but through digital catalog, or
digital collection through archives
that don't even necessarily need
to be using the same
subject vocabularies
that we use in libraries.
That's okay because
vocabulary developers, right,
controllers if you will, are
working very hard behind the scenes
to draw equivalences
across vocabularies.
And, in the linked data world, that
can actually become very seamless.
So, the most interesting linked data
projects to me and the ones that I
like to show to our students are
the ones that do the best work,
not just updating subject headings
not just making them internally
consistent, that's going to
be a Sisyphean effort, but,
leading people to the richness
of all of the stuff that we have,
collectively, as a society, all the
information that we have on topics
of interest, people of
interest, things like that.
That's a very rambling answer.
And, I don't know if I
answered the question.
But I try.
>> Mark Winek: Two more over here.
>> Dorothea Salo: Okay.
>> [Inaudible] currently
at George Mason University.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hi.
>> Cataloging librarian.
I think that administrators need to
hear what you said today much more
than we do because they're the ones
who basically tell us what to do.
And, when they're counting
how much work we do,
they don't say how many
errors did you fix today,
they want to know how many missed
errors have been processed.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hear, hear.
>> And, in some cases, I've read
that people have been specifically
forbidden to make correction
that they see needed work and.
>> Dorothea Salo: I
have heard this too.
It makes me so sad and so angry
because it's just making the work
down the line even
worse even harder.
>> Yes. Even in the members
of the OCLC Cooperative
where the demographic records are
not your records but our records.
>> Dorothea Salo: Oh
don't get me started.
I actually called out OCLC
on that one in person once.
>> Thank you for doing that.
>> Dorothea Salo: It was an
interesting conversation.
>> And, you may be familiar with
the type of the day project.
>> Dorothea Salo: Yeah.
>> Which began ten years ago based
on [inaudible] database of records.
That project is sort of [inaudible]
to a stop but needs to be revised,
perhaps not fixing individual
words but fixing entire strings.
That could be done
mechanically it's real dangerous.
>> Dorothea Salo: Some of it yeah.
>> To go in and try and fix
mechanically individual mistakes.
But, if you have a.
>> Dorothea Salo: If you
have a good testing tool,
if you can see what's going
to happen before it happens,
that's a great thing.
>> And having fixed numerous cases
of misspelled university
then gone back years later.
>> Dorothea Salo: Yep.
>> And found that 30
of them have crept
in because vendor records
contain them.
Vendors are the ones who
need to be tending to this.
They're.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hear, hear.
>> On a cache basis.
They have no motivation
to do anything other
than promulgate their wares.
>> Dorothea Salo: The
least possible yeah.
>> So, these are comments
that I have made.
And, I think a lot of
people who were involved
in various project have retired.
New people coming in need
to be trained in the fact
that these are the kind of
activities we need to be engaged in.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hear, hear.
And, I'm doing my best at the
library school where I'm yes.
But yes, 100% behind you.
>> Virginia Wayen: Hi.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hi.
>> Virginia Wayen:
I'm Virginia Wayen
from Frostburg State University.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hi Virginia.
>> Virginia Wayen: Hi.
I like to think that when we're
making [inaudible] like this,
that we think, for example,
not going where Google is
but where Google's going.
Are you aware of any of the things
that are just on the horizon now
that we need to be aware of
when we do these changes?
>> Dorothea Salo: Yeah.
One, that's a great question by the
way and thank you for asking it.
The next time you redesign
your website, right,
when you're redoing
all of your templates,
the next time you redesign
your digital collection
or even the next time
you scheme your catalogs,
look at something called
schema.org microdata.
And, you can learn about this at
schema.org, perhaps unsurprisingly.
So, the bit of history that
I didn't get into here is
that the webs first fling
with what is now linked data,
the semantic web, was
a complete flop.
Right. It didn't happen.
And, it didn't happen
because RDF is a beast.
Right. It's really hard to
learn past a certain relatively
simple point.
It's hard to implement.
And, web developers took
one look and ran screaming
in the opposite direction.
I can't blame them.
I don't like RDF either.
So, this time around the major
search engines, Google, Bing, Yahoo,
a couple others, I don't think
DuckDuckGo is involved though,
I think they should be.
If anybody here is in this room,
DuckDuckGo, please do that.
So, they got together and said
okay we need to break this
down and make it simpler.
And so, they came up with
a thing called microdata
that you can implement
directly in HTML
and it's got some very specific
vocabularies that you can use
to describe things like libraries.
The holy trinity of library
information, right, address, hours,
events, you can put
that in microdata
and then the search
engine can pick it up
and show it directly
in the search result.
If you do a Google search
on almost any current movie,
you will see much richer information
that you used to because IMDB,
the Internet Movie Data Base
has implemented microdata very
effectively and Google
picks up on that.
In the Code4Lib Journal, a couple
of other places there are examples
of libraries improving
their search results
and actually moving
up on search results pages
because of microdata.
So, the one thing, if you had to
pin me down to one thing that's
on the horizon that I
think is worth looking at,
I would say microdata check it out.
Next time you're doing a redesign,
see what you can implement.
>> Mark Winek: I think we have time
for just one more quick
question right here.
>> Kari Brady: Hi.
I'm Kari Brady.
I'm from Maryland's Department
of Legislative Services.
>> Dorothea Salo: Hi Kari.
>> Kari Brady: And,
I have a question
about making more consistent records
that describe items
that are inconsistent.
We, most of our cataloging.
>> Dorothea Salo: Wonderful
[inaudible].
>> Kari Brady: Yeah.
Most of our cataloging is
government agency reports
and task force reports and all that.
>> Dorothea Salo: Yeah.
>> Kari Brady: Fun stuff.
And, many of them are
annual or, you know,
at least serialized in some way.
And unfortunate.
>> Dorothea Salo: Are you serious?
>> Kari Brady: Yeah.
Unfortunately, because they're not,
you know, published by a publisher
who wants to be, you know,
wants to be found again,
so has some steak in
being consistent.
>> Dorothea Salo: Yeah.
>> Kari Brady: They are quite often
they change titles very frequently,
which isn't as big a deal because
you've got all those 246's.
>> Dorothea Salo: Right.
>> Kari Brady: But, they
change formats frequently.
They change even the laws
that require the reports
change frequently.
And, sometimes, those get
to be a real mess as far
as tracking those in the record.
But then, the biggest problem comes
in when they've done
something strange about, well,
they skipped a year here but they
made it up in this other one.
And so, the dates are all messed up.
And the patrons are going to be
looking for them but they don't know
that they actually split this
report up into this report
and also this other report
that's shelved over here.
And so, with some of these records,
we end up with a zillion
five hundred notes.
>> Dorothea Salo: Right.
Because.
>> Kari Brady: And of
course they're free text.
>> Dorothea Salo: Those marks
doesn't give you any other way
to represent that.
>> Kari Brady: Exactly.
>> Dorothea Salo: Right?
>> Kari Brady: And sometimes
it's so complicated that it has
to be free text because
there's really no.
>> Dorothea Salo: How
in the world else.
>> Kari Brady: Standardized.
>> Dorothea Salo: Would you
tell even a human being what
in the world is going on here?
Yeah.
>> Keri Brady: Yeah.
>> Dorothea Salo: So,
explaining things
to human beings we shall
always have with us.
Here's what I'll say about that.
Linked data, because it is
intrinsically granular, right,
you've probably all heard the idea
that we're exploding the record
and we're making statements.
Part of the reason we're doing that
is that the record is kind of a,
since I'm on my Greek Latin
kick today, procrustean bed.
We lop off anything
that we have to lop off
to make whatever we're
describing fit the record.
I think linked data will
let us stop doing that.
And, I think, particularly, for when
you have these strange edge cases
and for formats that MARC has
never dealt real well with,
there's a great Code4Lib
Journal article
from a computer programmer
trying to get to grips
with how MARC handles music scores.
Right? Exactly.
I think we will expand into a
world that's much kinder to things
that don't quite fit
the catalog card model
that was designed for books.
That's my hope anyway,
that's my hope.
>> Kari Brady: Thanks.
>> Dorothea Salo: Sure.
Well thank you all.
This has been a lot of fun.
>> Mark Wiken: Thank you.
>> So we're, I think our
presentation today is going
to compliment Dorothea's
actually nicely.
We are going to try to help
you prepare to be linked.
I'm going to give kind
of a high level talk
and then Jackie will get more down
in the dirt and give the real meat
of some things you can do.
>> Nancy Fallgren: Okay.
So, how many of you have been
to linked data talks before?
How familiar is this slide?
I hate Legos.
I'm getting this out of the way now.
This is the obligatory Legos side.
We're done, it's over.
No more. Okay?
I was just talking to
someone about stepping on them
and how painful that can be.
There are many reasons
not to like Legos.
So, back when I was a library
school student, at the University
of Maryland, Dale Flecker from
Harvard came to speak to us
about the future of
libraries and technology.
And, the presentation that he gave
was full of such doom and gloom
that I walked away thinking why am
I even bothering to get this degree.
And, basically what he, he
painted this really dire picture
of the inabilities, the inability
of libraries to ever catch
up with technology
because we are so bogged
down by our processes we're not
agile enough to make any progress.
So, what I'd like to
say to you is, yes,
I'm on the linked data bandwagon
because linked data gives me hope.
It gives me hope that
we can significantly
or at least a lot decrease
that technology gap.
I think we're at a crossroads.
I think behind us is the
comfort of what we know,
a technology that we've
been using for 65 years
that we feel warm and fuzzy about.
And, on the other side, is
an opportunity to progress
to a more kind technology, along
with all the anxiety and discomfort
that comes with change
and unfamiliar territory.
But, if we can embrace this change
now and adopt agile practices, then,
perhaps, we can actually
gain ground on technology.
And maybe, moving forward, we can
catch up and maybe even keep up.
So, MARC is behind me at
the crossroad or behind us
at the crossroad at our backs and
linked data is in front of us.
At a high level, a change to linked
data is a change from operating
in silo databases to working
with technology that's
aligned with the semantic web.
It'll force us to be more aware
of how the resources we're working
with are related and how
our data works on the web.
All right.
So, I mention semantic web.
I really hope, my,
one of my dreams is
that I will never have
to explain this again.
I really hope that this slide can
be thrown away within the next year.
So, what is the semantic web?
The semantic web is
simply a web of data.
It's a more granular web
than the one we're used to.
The web we're used to links
documents to documents.
The semantic web links data to data.
the language of the semantic web
is resource description framework
or RDF.
And, RDF is expressed in triples.
Triples look like simple sentence,
subject, predicate, object.
The idea behind triples is
that they should be expressed,
or that the data, the pieces of the
triples, the subject, the predicate,
and the object are
preferably expressed as IRI's.
And this is a different acronym
than the one that Dorothea used.
She talked about URI's.
Jackie and I are going
to say IRI instead.
So, what is an IRI?
An IRI is an internationalized
resource identifier.
It's URI that's basically
internationalized.
So, what does that mean?
URI uses a limited character set.
IRI uses a universal character set
to allow expression
in non-Latin scripts.
So, the idea is that IRI's can
then be round tripped back to URI's
and then to other languages.
So, it's an internationalization
of URI.
So, if I am Chinese, I
can see URI in Chinese
and understand what it's saying,
you can see it in my own language.
We may go back and forth a little
bit, Jackie and I, between IRI
and URI, but I think, mostly,
mostly you'll be hearing us say IRI.
So, we just wanted to
make that explanation.
And, Jackie will be going into this
in detail when she talks to it.
One of the really important things
to keep in mind, when you're talking
about linked data and the semantic
web and you're talking about RDF,
and this is the concept
that I think, sometimes,
people or catalogers may
have difficulty grasping
because we think in
terms of records.
No more records.
We're talking, in RDF,
about pieces of data.
So, you don't have a record to
give each piece of data context.
Each triple has to be understandable
on its own out in the world.
It has to be able to sit out
in the world and make sense.
No record to give it context.
The context of the object of
the triple is its subject.
Okay? Important concept,
really important concept
to digest and understand.
So, first let's start by, we'll talk
about how we can prepare
ourselves for linked data.
And, I am right up there
with Dorothea learn,
learn, learn, learn, learn.
So, one of the things
that we can do in advance
of this becoming a
standard for us to use,
because, it's not a standard.
It's not an adopted standard
for us to be using right now.
Right? We're preparing.
We're preparing so that, when
we cross that road, it's not,
it's not so anxiety filled, we
can mitigate some of the anxiety
that comes with change
with learning.
And, when I'm talking about
learning, I'm saying explore,
buy a book, do it on your own.
Look through the web,
there are places at W3C
where you can learn
about linked data.
There are, there's information about
linked data all over the place.
You can take formal
linked data training.
There is that available.
If you're an administrator, I would
say to you have discussion groups.
Invite your staff to sit down and
maybe have a regular brown bag lunch
where they can talk about their
thoughts their concerns and learn
from each other, from
each other's learning.
Make it an open discussion.
And then, if your staff or
you, your library can do it,
get involved in experimentation
of some kind.
It doesn't hurt to be playing with
things, you can't break anything
because none of it
is real right now.
It's just play.
It's all just play right now.
One of the things that we need
to do is adjust the way we think.
Right? So, as I said, we
need to think in terms
of data rather than records.
So, for example, MARC allows us to
say that a bib record was created
by one entity and then edited
or modified by other entities.
I hate the 041.
But, at a data level,
we can't identify.
When you look at a MARC record, you
have absolutely no idea what piece
of data OC created, NOM modified,
and George Washington
University completely replaced.
You don't know.
All you know is that those
institutions touched that record
and that you think those
institutions do good
cataloging work.
So, do we really need to know?
Do we really need to
know exactly what piece
of data any particular institution
contributes to MARC record.
We don't know it now.
Why would we insist on knowing
that in a linked data environment?
Every time we use a triple,
every time we go out on the web
and pull something in, and
Dorothea's illustration
of copy cataloging, going out
and pulling in different pieces,
every time we pull a piece of data
in, we are asserting that that piece
of data is an authoritative piece of
data that we believe that that piece
of data is true and accurate.
So, does it matter
where it comes from?
Does it matter who originally
created it if it is true
and accurate because that's
really what we're shooting
for in the end is accuracy?
So, there's conversion
programs out there right now,
a couple conversion, a
legacy MARC to link data.
That conversion will be Lossy.
Get used to it.
Go with it.
Move on. We are not
having MARC in RDF.
There's MARC data that just
doesn't necessarily make sense.
What we need to do, when we're
looking at this conversion
of legacy MARC is to think
about what do we need?
What can we afford to lose?
There's a lot of redundant
data in MARC.
Right? what can we afford to lose
and what do we really need to keep
and who are we keeping it for?
If we've been recording some
piece of data for 65 years
because some day somebody may
want to use it, and no one has
or it's been used twice,
I say throw it away.
I clean out my closet at
the end of every season.
If I have not worn something
that season, it goes to Goodwill.
We need to start thinking
in those terms.
I know it's a little harsh.
But, it keeps my closet reasonable.
So, some of the best training,
most that I've ever had was
agile development training.
The idea is that you
assess requirements,
you develop a solution,
and then you reassess,
you decide if the solution
still works,
and you may revise the solution.
And then, you go back and you
reassess, revise the solution.
It's an iterative process.
And, one of the things that we
need to think about, if we're going
to keep up with technology and
we're going to keep moving along,
if we take this linked data path and
we're going to keep moving forward
and we're not going to be left
behind the way we've been left
behind with MARC, we are never done.
The process is never, there
is no such thing as finished.
It is, you're always iterating.
You have to get used to that.
You have to start thinking that
the data may still all be there,
might be called something, might
be tagged a little differently,
it might show up a
little differently,
dates may be formatted differently,
because five years from now we find
out there's a better
way to format dates
than anybody's been doing before.
It's okay.
Change is good.
Change is okay as long as
we keep moving forward.
So, I want to talk a little
bit about preparing data.
And, I think I can cut some of this
out because I think Dorothea
covered this really well.
So, what can we do?
What can we do to prepare
for linked data?
We have data model
development going on.
So, what does that mean?
We had a question, I'm sorry
I didn't, I couldn't see
who asked the question
about serials.
So, okay, so in an environment
where you're looking at every piece
of data and how ever piece of data
relates to another piece of data,
you have to think about how do we
model that data so that it describes
when you group it, or when you
pull pieces of it together,
it describes what you need
it to describe in a good way,
in the way that you want it done?
Right? So, you have the title.
Serial has title.
Serial has title, title.
You have serial has
publisher, publisher.
You have serial changed frequency.
Ah oh, what do we do now?
Right? Maybe what we do
is we model a data event
and we say serial had event.
Change frequency.
And then, we move from there.
We have to think about how we can
say these things in linked data,
the things that we need to say,
need to say, how do we say them
so that they make sense and
that the stupid computers
and the stupid programs that
we use can put it all together
and have it make sense to
someone else looking at it?
And, work like this is going on.
NLM has been working with
George Washington University,
University California Davis, and
Sephora to model a big frame on,
a big frame of linked
data model for motographs.
We started with low hanging fruit
and we actually published
that back in December.
Sephora, if you are an
alumni of Sephora, training,
they have alumni cast groups that
they're putting together now to work
on data modeling for
specific types of resources.
And, anyone can join those.
If you have to have gone through
training but you can join those
and you also can follow them.
If you, even if you can't
join, you can follow.
There's a concert group that's been
put together also that's been put
together to talk about
modeling for serials.
So, there are things out there.
And then, of course there
are the LD4 projects,
LD4 and LD4P where they're
also looking at, part of those,
part of those projects is looking
at how they model data
for certain resources.
So, if you can't do
these things, you,
or be part of these
particular things,
you can at least follow them.
And, you can locally
warn institutions.
Start to think about, start to
think about how would I model,
serials are a great one,
how would I model a serial?
How would I, how would
I make this look?
And then, you can contribute
what you know to lists,
you can contribute it to groups,
contribute it however you can.
We already have a bunch of
RDF ontologies or schema.
There are a lot out there.
And, we need to start thinking
about which ones do we want to use
or which pieces of
ones do we want to use.
For example, there's one called
ProGo that has really nice modeling
for providence information.
Maybe we want to use big frame and
then also use some ProGo predicates
when we're describing something.
So, we need to start thinking
about that as internally.
What are we doing within
our library?
But then, we also need to think
about what are we going to,
are we going to have preferred
ontologies or preferred schema
for certain kinds of
information certain kinds of data
across libraries so
that we can make sure
that we're all talking
the same language
or speaking the same language
that we can all link together.
Whose data do you want to use?
Whose authoritative
data do you want to use?
I have a colleague at UC Davis
who, her dream is to have an ISSN,
plug it into a form, have that form
send it out to the ISBN portal,
pick up linked data from the ISB
portal and populate her form.
It's a great dream.
But, she needs to talk to the people
at the ISS or the ISSN portal,
so she needs to talk to people
at the ISSN portal if she wants
to make it happen because they
have to know that she's interested.
So, at NLM we just finished
or we haven't finished,
but we are closing a data project
where we publish MESH in RDF.
The way that came about was, as part
of the frame, early experimenters,
Eric Miller of Sephora, the
first time I met him, sat me down
and said I need to talk to you.
And we sat over dinner and all he
kept telling me were used cases
that he knew of that where
people wanted to use MESH in RDF.
And that was the impetus, that
was what got that project started.
So, you have to tell people
that you want to use your data.
They have to know that there's
a need for their data in RDF
to give them the impetus to change
it over so that you can use it.
And we need to, we need
to expose our authorities.
And, I think, Dorothea
covered this really well.
If you've got a name authority
or if you've got something,
a local name authority, your
professors, your faculty,
get those names into, you know,
the shared authority files.
Get those names into VIAP or
Orchid, or Iznio [assumed spellings]
or whatever, so that your
faculty can get out there,
so that people can
find your faculty,
you can link to your faculty,
people can link to your faculty.
Share that stuff so that
those names are out there
and they can be used by others.
So, when we're recording data,
and again, Dorothea hit on this,
we need to think about
best practices.
Here's a PCC, and Jackie's going
to talk a little bit about this
because she leads the group, but
there's a PCC task group on URI's
that started, all really kind of
got started when Steve Fulsome
from Cornell University
shared a paper,
white paper that he had written with
some friends about the many ways
that identifiers are
recorded in MARC and the need
for a consistent way to
record identifiers in MARC
so that we could convert them
into actionable IRI's,
actionable HTTP IRI's.
You could do that.
If you see a need, what he
did was, he wrote that paper,
somebody said to him you know what,
you should bring that to MAC at ALA.
And, he brought it to MAC and
the folks at MAC said, you know,
you really need to
bring that to the PCC.
So, he brought it to the PCC.
And now there's a PCC task group
looking into best practices
for the creation of IRI's or URI's.
If you see a need, get
the ball rolling, say it,
collaborate, let people speak.
Speak. Tell people.
I think if we do this, or this
doesn't look to me like it's going
to work because it's a
string not an identifier
or there are some different
ways to format this identifier.
How can we make this better?
If you see that need, participate.
And, I am so in agreement we need
to deemphasize transcription.
I mean, some things, you can't
help, you got to transcribe a title,
you got to transcribe
right, it's a title.
But, but, roman numerals, really?
Really? It drives me
absolutely insane.
I don't think people even know
what they mean half the time,
forget computers.
Right? It's just, really
lets drop the roman numerals.
And then, there are
other things like that.
Right? There are other
things like that.
If you really look at the MARC
data, really take a look and see,
do I need to transcribe this or
can I do this a different way?
Another thing that we can look at
now that we can, we can start seeing
as looking at the linked data
pilots and some of the tools.
So, Library of Congress has got
a whole bunch of tools, right,
that they're putting out and making
available for you to use and play
with and experiment with.
Sephora has some tools.
UC Davis is working on making
available a cataloging module
that will have the data
entry user interface
and you can then see what your
data looks like as linked data.
There's also RIMMF, that
Deborah Fritz has put out.
So, there are things out
there that you can play with.
Play with these things, take a
look, see what it looks like.
And then, you can actually
you can make suggestions.
You can say you know I would really
like this better if it did this
or this would work better
for me if it did that.
Right. So, Sephora's one of the
things, the Sephora's tool is
that they you can actually
go out and, if you're looking
for an authority or name authority,
you can say I want to see the LCNAF,
the LC name authority and
it'll give you a little box
and it'll show you what the data is.
right n ow, it's only
machine readable.
So, one of the things you can
tell Sephora is hey you know what,
I need this to be human readable
because this makes no
sense to me right now.
This doesn't help me to
distinguish it from anything else.
You can play with these
things, you can make comment,
you can help effect
how they are developed.
So, we can also prepare
for discovery.
You'll like this one Dorothea.
We, this is from the Treasurer
of the Tres Riches Heures du Duc de
Berry 15th Century Book of Hours.
We need to, we need to
seed the semantic web.
We need to seed it with
authoritative data.
Our standard vocabularies,
subjects, subjects MESH LC, LCSH.
Some of this work is
already being done.
Right. National Agricultural
Library has done this with,
and if there's anyone here
forgive me is it [inaudible]?
And, you know, name authorities.
All of these things,
these are all seeds,
these are all that we get
these standard vocabularies
out there identified in a standard
way and then we can link to them.
But, if we have nothing to link to,
if I want to, if I'm, if I'm an NRM
and I'm cataloging, I'm trying
to catalog with some a book
in linked data and we only
use MESH subject headings,
and MESH is not available
on RDF, I'm stuck.
Right? How's anybody on the web
going to find those subject headings
if given a linked data environment?
And, we think, we need to take,
this is, I lie awake at night
and think about these things.
But, with the prospect of, I
don't know, hundreds of thousands
of libraries, I don't even know
how many libraries there are
across the world.
Right. Exposing their collections
as linked data on the web, I think,
there's going to be an
information explosion.
Maybe I'm wrong, maybe
there's some way
to manage this that
I don't understand.
But, how will libraries manage that?
Right? So, we want our local
constituents to be able
to find our resources easily.
But, not all our users are local.
And, we want our collections to
be discovered across the world.
So, everybody has a
copy, not everybody, but,
most people probably have a
copy of Grey's Anatomy, right.
That's not one of those things
that is unique to any one library.
But, Marshall Nirenberg's Nobel
Prize is unique to the NLM.
We want people to know that
that's there to be able to find it
and maybe be able to see it if we've
got a photo of it or his collections
to be able to find those.
Those are the things we
really want to stress.
Right. So those are the things
that I think we need
to think about first.
Sure, it's easy to model
books as Low Hanging Fruit.
Serials need to be done too.
But, you know what,
nearly everybody's got a
copy of Jama somewhere.
Right? Everybody's got a
copy of Nature somewhere.
Not everybody has a copy of
Marshall Nirenberg's papers.
When Diana, so one of the things
that I think we need to think
about is can we work with
the search engine providers?
Can we work with them to help
get our expose our library data
in a way that's manageable that
doesn't explode people's brains?
When I worked, I was a consultant
to the working group on the future
of bibliographic control which
Deanna Marcum put together.
And one of the things she
did was to invite Google
and Microsoft to the table.
And, they agreed to join.
They were at every meeting.
They were at every, every public
presentation that went on.
And, behind the scenes
they worked with us.
Maybe it's time for us
to reopen that door.
Maybe we need to talk to them
and say these are our concerns.
Maybe you have a way to manage this.
Maybe we can figure out
together a way to manage this.
Maybe you don't care.
Maybe, we can work with them.
So, this is, this is
a knowledge graph.
So, Dorothea talked before
about using schema
markup, microdata markup.
This is a knowledge
graph from Google, which,
if you look up Marie Curie,
this is that thing that shows
up on the right side of the screen
and gives you some information.
And, this is all linked data.
This is all coming from Schema.
Libraries aren't here anywhere.
You've got quotes.
Right. You've got a little bit of
biographical information quotes
and then you've got
people also search for.
What if, what if it also included
resources in libraries and museums?
What if there was a way to say, hum,
you know there's so many millions
of pieces of data coming in from
libraries, what if we group it?
Oops. And, even better, what if
we can group it, because we have
such great data, and
say I want literature,
I can show you literature
by Marie Curie,
we can show you literature
about her.
We can show you her letters.
We can show you her
manuscript archive collections.
We can show you images
and we can show you film.
What if we give them?
We can even give them some facets
because we do have such great data.
Something to think about.
So, at the heart of all the
stuff that I've been talking
about is the ability
to link our data.
And, ultimately, that can't happen
if we don't use IRI's instead
of strings wherever we can.
So, I'm going to turn this over
to Jackie now who is the IRI guru.
And, she will talk to you about
her experiences with IRI's.
>> Jackie Shieh: So, the
secret is the identifier.
And so, with this,
the secret is out.
So, my portion, hopefully
will not disappoint you is
that how TW intended
to bring that down
to our routine daily
operation level.
And, as you know, my long
journey with electronic resources.
I was at UVA playing with TI
Header and I was at University
of Michigan I was working
with Google Books,
working with finding things out
in copyright and now our print.
And now, I'm in GW working
with a group of staff to figure
out how we could expose our data.
So, Nancy eluded to earlier the IRI
and this is what my focus is going
to be is making sure that we are
looking at a script that is usable
across different domain and
it is accessible globally.
With that in mind, I think, everyone
by now has an idea the triples.
And, the second I that
Nancy eluded to eluded
to [inaudible] is the focus
of what and RDF statement is,
is this identifier that is unique.
And, it is universal.
Now, the thing is, with this IRI,
it has to be that it can
provide linking asset
through a variety of
networks globally.
So, this is essentially is, if you
were to work with an RDF statement,
you can see that an
identifier is an typical element
of this identification process.
So, why do we put so much emphasis
on understanding an identifier?
And, from this point forward, I'm
going to just use the word IRI.
It facilitate the exposure,
inhale, transmit,
and exchange all data
by the networks.
Now, when it is persistent,
unambiguous, and uniform syntax,
and it is consistent over
time, it is of high value
because you were allowed computer
to not only understand the content
but also derive knew knowledge
about reasoning about that content.
And, that is the key.
In an IDF environment
where the process
of URI is shows how
this allows the machine
to not only understand what is being
connected but also have the ability
to reason and derive
new knowledge from it.
And then, that is how the
web of data gets created
and the URI is undeniable
the hallmark
of whole process the link open data.
TW has been fortunate to have been
able to participate in the process
of different initiatives as an early
experimenter and a test implementer
and experience with National
Library of Medicine, they say begin
to contemplate the approach,
the modular approach.
We were fortunate enough to
be at the table and observe
and participate so, how do we get
to where we are right now is simply
because through the grueling process
of two years that we participated
in those different initiatives,
we went through numerous webinar,
study halls, exercises, pair studies
that made us realize that we need
to begin to have a
vision within this.
What do I want to do with my
profession, to move forward
to be counted in this
web aligned servers?
How are we going to learn to be
able to make use of the skills,
the knowledge that we could
already have and contribute
to the wider world of the
knowledge of information sphere?
So, throughout this process,
we begin to have our a vision how
we can move together as a team.
We learn how to facilitate that
[inaudible] through the process
that open source software
make available to us.
And my hearing from Dorothea
sharing the skillset, I must say,
I was really comforted
to know, two years ago,
I couldn't have said this,
in front of all of you.
But, now, my team, the only
skills that we are in lack of,
in need of, is [inaudible].
We have every single one that
Dorothea mentioned on her slide.
And, it took three years.
It took three years constantly
learning and throughout the process.
So, you know, it is not difficult
for all of us here to sit aside time
and communicate to your
manager, your supervisor
and say this is, I have a vision.
I'd like to do this.
Do I have the time?
You give me the time.
How I can adjust my workload
in order to accomplish that?
Because, this is event,
you know, ultimately,
it's a great contribution
to the profession.
So, in that, we began to consider
how then we could continue
our experimentation.
How can we use this in
the MARC environment?
How is it that the RDF
linking concept can be expanded
in our current IOS system?
So, here's some of the questions
that, before we started, we had to,
there's a way to attempt to answer.
IRI in MARC, with MARC
we encode data in MARC.
You would have to decide
the field where it goes.
And then, you have to know
is there a set field for it?
And so, how did this relate to
the process that we already learn
when we were experimenting
different?
In order to accomplish
that, what type of workflow
and changes must take place
so that we could accomplish this
little tiny bit of the process?
And so, we began investigating
and doing research.
So, the first thing we found
on the MARC standard side
were this is instruction.
It is, there is ability for us
to play with the data and for,
in our case, we didn't really quite
understand, when we first began
in 2013, September, we didn't quite
understand how we can construct
those using the form that
we're most interested in.
And, we did not know
what kind of impact
that the data would do
to avoid your system.
So, our focus is on
nonliteral surrogate value
which is the HTTP URI
not the text read
because over the years we've
been playing with data.
We've been shifting our
mindset from putting in stream,
thinking the stream in
terms of stream is data.
So then, what else?
Because we are also an OCLC library
in addition, we need to know what
that means in an OCLC environment.
And, unfortunately, we
can't do anything in OCLC.
This is the guideline
basically said nothing can,
we could not do anything
with Sephora 0.
So, that essentially opened up the
door for us to experiment locally
in a local voyager system.
So, before that, we also
began to find to see
if we could locate other
type of usage in Sephora 0
that already in connection.
And, most of them we found this
format that's very much like the 035
that everyone was aware of.
So, will put an organization
code within purines followed
by another numeric identifier.
You could also use the international
standard code that is provided.
And, you can find that at
the Library of Congress site
with the identifier associated
with that particular service.
So, along with all of this
research that we have gained so far,
we began to test our data.
And, our favorite example
was Miss Jen Olson's work.
So, in 2013, we extracted about
less than 100 Jen Olson's work
to see how well we can do.
We [inaudible] IRI
in the [inaudible]
at the same time we have the
stream base IRI, stream base IRI
in the system, we populated in
the name heading, set the heading
and the tracing which
is now the 700s area.
We loaded about 500 Sephora 0
[inaudible] Voyager back in 2013.
And to our surprise and
perhaps a sigh of relief,
we didn't break the system.
It just simply be there.
It just simply there.
Our web services did
not even notice.
And so they, nobody shout out
and said what are you doing.
So, so we, we, so, let it sit for
a little bit before we move forward
with it because we didn't
quite understand the impact
of an identifier in an
IRI HTTP environment.
And, the reason we finally
settle that if we were
to move forward putting
identifier in IRI Voyager,
we were up to do a HTTP IRI.
And, these are some of the reasons
that convince us that
is the route to go.
And one opportunity came, and I
think all of you probably have
that in your environment.
In 2014, August, our
Student Committee,
TW is part of the Washington
Research Library Association.
One of the initiatives that was
set out by the Student Committee
as a 2015 initiative was to
develop and implement a plan
that would successfully transition
library's demographic records
to the new library system
platform including consolidating
to a single record
addressing authority control
and tine implementation of RDA.
Now, one of the very first thing was
identify by the Metadata Committee,
was perhaps, most of
you are not unfamiliar
with is the reclamation
process with OCLC.
So, I don't think I need to go into
detail what reclamation does or is.
So, we began our reclamation
project in October of 2014
which initiated a process.
But, the whole project didn't
actually start until January
because we used that
about three months process
to identify strategies, develop a
plan, and how it would be workable
with limited staff that we have.
And also, through all this process,
I'd been talking too Terry Reese
because back in August of 2014,
he had mind to begin populating
his [inaudible] additional tools
to prepare libraries
for linked data.
And the first thing he put
in that tool was different
transformation tool.
So had it not for [inaudible] we
had to go through grueling process
of writing code in Perl,
which that I'm familiar with,
utilizing a series of
Perl modules like LIBCURL,
Library Client URL Protocol, LWP,
LW in Perl to query data
against RDF services.
So, from March to May, as soon as
we get a report back from OCLC.
You know that our data
has part OCLC.
Our next step is we need to put
our data back into our system.
So, at that time, we were
thinking, if we were to do that,
we can now take this
opportunity to enhance our data.
We, the commission project,
essentially, we were thinking
of doing close to two
million TW records.
But, we have passed
it out in phases.
And that the phase one was the
almost a million [inaudible]
and it was 999,785 type records.
So, it's a little bit shy of a one
million records per physical pieces.
So that's means book, serial, DVD,
CD, CD rom and all of the above.
We didn't, we left out
electronic resources
because we were advised
to do it differently.
So, that's where we are by now.
So, with that process, we ran, we
talked to Terry Reese and worked
with him with troubleshooting.
And he put, made available these
tools which is fabulous, fabulous.
We ran our records, we select the
Sephora 0 that we wanted to input.
The service that he made available
through his link data lookup,
the triple source that are
available is humongous.
But, we just wanted to test to see
if we just had one
and what it would do.
And, I must tell you, with five
dedicated machines, three very,
three plus a troubleshooter,
so now fourth staff member,
dedicated staff member
that months of July
and August was sleepless night for
many of us, for many of us there.
Now, Terry Reese recently also
added comment line process.
And, that is tremendously helpful
because I am a comment line person.
So, I can stack the
command and prompt feeding
in my 390 files at a different time.
and so, from the last week of
June to the last week of August,
there's a reason why we
had to get it done was
because of school starting
the first week of September.
And, we had to make sure all
our records are accessible
and ready for our students.
And, this is what he will
see before July 26, I think,
this is what before we are, the
actual replacement took place.
And, we couldn't have done this
without our WRLC colleagues standing
alongside and being with us.
I think the latest they worked was
like 10pm and, I work early hours.
So, when I get up at
five I saw my files.
So, that really worked
out very well.
We, our record right now
had gone through RDA,
so our records are RDA compliant
with Sephora 0 GDP IRI available.
And, as of September
1st, this is our stats.
Close to four million
Sephora 0 in our Voyager data.
99.35% of them resulted from
our reclamation project.
I think this is really doable.
And, you know, need a little
bit of organizational, you know,
talking through with
your administrator,
talking through with your team.
If you really are fretting this
programing side of the activities,
talk to your programing IT folks.
It doesn't take them that long
to come up with a solution.
So, for now, this point forward
for us, we now, we could worry less
about a lot of the process
that are traditional,
cataloging data management processes
that we could begin to focus
on the following, understanding what
type of ontologies IP services are
out there, the vocabulary
allow us to do a different type
of data modeling so that we
can serve our communities,
broaden their horizon.
We came to understand that linked
data ecosystems will enable our
researchers to have
their research exposed
to have their research
be elevated to the level
that they are easily found.
And, the metadata that we are
created, we are creating right now,
reach beyond our library walls and
the technology that is associated
with this will work
efficiently with the data.
And this is not just library data,
this is data across the globe.
And, this activity,
like Nancy eluded
to earlier, have been noted by PCC.
PCC called a task group together
with a fine group of members
and it's, and an extremely,
extremely stellar group
of professionals serving
as consultants.
This team's going to take us some
time, it's going to take some time
for this team to come together
making recommendations.
But we are making good progress
in terms of looking through what's
out there, what's being done,
and what is the feasible.
And one thing that it's
reading in our mind is
when we make a recommendation,
it will be an incremental
recommendation for change.
It will not be something so
drastic that the rug will be pulled
under your feet and you
have nothing to hold on to.
Now how many of you
are Ex Libris customers
that are using either Primo or Alma?
Oh, not many.
Okay. How many of you
are Sirsi customers?
Okay, now then this just came out.
If you are a user, customers of
Ex Libris that are using Alma
and Primo, a call has gone
out this Monday, okay?
Sirsi Dynex has provided a widget
in their BLUEcloud for libraries
to generate identifiers associated
with that entity that
they are creating.
Mind you, this is for discovery.
What I shared earlier
is the raw data
that we are providing our
users and our IT folks.
This, it's great for Sirsi and
Ex libris, but they don't come
down to our local system.
They stay with the discovery layer.
What I am promoting is for all of
us, if you can find a way to get it
in your system, whichever it may be,
it could be [inaudible],
follow the standard.
Your library discovery
team would love this.
Because when I, when we made an
announcement internally, by the way,
this is the first public
forum I'm sharing this,
so you are the first to know.
This is not widely known that GW
had almost four meetings [inaudible]
in HTTP actionable
IRI in the system.
In fact, when we started, we
shared with Library of Congress,
Library of Congress has less
than 200 [inaudible] embedded
and they are not HTTP IRI.
So this is really phenomenal
for our discovery team.
They are writing programs
because they,
this has just happened
like last month.
So we are waiting to see how
this will impact our service.
But as I'm sharing earlier, when we
tested it in 2013, nothing happened.
Okay? So you will not break
your system, I don't think.
So, you know, test it.
And then let it be known that there
is this subset, there's this pilot,
and see what your discovery
team can do with it.
And I must say that GW
wasn't the single institution
in this country testing it.
They have many people testing it.
They are just probably the first
one to put it in production.
And this is our retrospective
process for reclamation,
but for the ongoing, incoming
title, we have, we are running
through marc edit, [inaudible].
Now I know for sure, European
libraries are doing this locally.
It's just right now, simply because
[inaudible] zero, the URI, the IRI,
the format you use in marc
environment hasn't been settled,
so a lot of people are asked
and they're not sure how
to contribute this data back
into a utility such as OCLC
and like I shared earlier, you see
OCLC said no to [inaudible] zero.
So a lot of these things are all
happening locally, Swedish Library,
the National Library of Spain,
German National Library,
British Library, these
are the libraries
that we should be keeping tabs
on what they are doing locally.
And soon enough, hopefully
all of this data
in individual systems will
benefit all of us at large.
So I'm going to leave you this,
that I love, there is a tide
in the affairs of men, which taken
at the flood, leads on to fortune.
Omitted all the voyage
of their life is bound
in shallows and in miseries.
On such a full sea are we now
afloat, and we must take the current
where it serves or lose our
fortune, ventures, sorry.
This is from Shakespeare,
The Tragedy of Julius Caesar.
Thank you.
>> Mark Winek: Thank you to both,
thank you to both Nancy and Jackie.
And I'd invite both
of them to come up.
I think we have time
for about two questions.
I don't want to.
>> Jackie Shieh: Sorry.
>> Mark Winek: That's okay.
>> Mark Winek: Two
or three questions
and then we can run into lunch.
So I'll start over there with Chris.
>> Carla: Hey, Jackie.
>> Jackie Shieh: Hi, Carla.
>> Carla: I remember one year ago,
we both talked to a global scholar,
Dr. Acharya, who is the
founder of the Google Scholar.
>> Jackie Shieh: The Google Scholar.
>> Carla: Jackie, yeah, we lobby
him to help library to come
up with more meaningful and
indexing way in the Google Scholar
so that make library
resource available
in that [inaudible] platform.
One thing I remember he mentioned
about is the question of a URI?
>> Jackie Shieh: Yeah.
>> Carla: Yeah.
You mentioned about IRI,
do you think that did
not answer his question,
that one day everything would just
go to one unique identifier so that
like it will not be mixed with,
if our library say subject heading
on name had a [inaudible]
linked to Wikipedia,
one day they can really talk to each
other with a unique [inaudible].
Is that possible?
>> Jackie Shieh: I think right
now you can see that example
in [inaudible] that is in abrogated
services collecting all the
identifiers established by
multiple national library services
for one single entity in one place.
So how it will essentially
play out is where,
I think Dorothea mentioned,
you know, we need to figure
out what would be the
authoritative service
that we will promote and use.
Now when I say the world IRI,
I mean that you use a script,
you notice that the
script was different
when you were using a
unicode versus non unicode.
So that's for machine to translate.
If you were to use IRI
with the same value,
and the newer system cannot read
IRI, it will translate your,
the thing within this
environment, the machine,
we were expecting machine
to work smarter.
I'm sorry Dorothea.
We have expectations that a
machine should be usually smarter,
so that it would take our IRI, if
your local system cannot ingest IRI,
to get it back into the URI
so you can still get to
where you need to go.
>> Carla: Okay.
I just noticed in your record
in [inaudible] there are
two [inaudible] zero.
>> Jackie Shieh: In 2013,
we have actually 3, or 4,
or 5, because we are testing.
>> Carla: Okay.
So each of them.
>> Jackie Shieh: They all the same,
they all lead to the
same authority data,
it's just they're formed
differently,
they are HTTP versus stream,
that using [inaudible]
and then the alphanumeric
identifier value.
>> Carla: Okay, get it.
Last question.
Okay. I'm sorry.
Maybe I'll ask you later.
>> Mark Winek: We have
a question over here.
>> Hi, Jackie.
>> Hi.
>> Hi. Earlier you mentioned that
you had chosen not to add IRI's,
or at least not through marc
edit, for your e-resources
because something else
was recommended.
Could you describe that?
>> Jackie Shieh: Yes.
I think because we have such a
composite practices over the years
for electronic resources and it's
rather difficult, maybe it's easy
for you, but it was quite difficult
for my team to really figure
out the, because, okay, back to
the sense are we talking about ICN,
we use ICN, when we are searching
for one ISBN and then we realize oh,
this is actually the
print ISBN, but we brought
up the electronic resource
ISB record.
So then we actually have
multiple records and then we have
to go deeper to figure it out.
Is this the right ISBN for
this right e-resources?
So that's why we decided to hold off
on the electronic resources
through this process.
However, we were recommended
to use collation manager in WMS
to set our hold that
our ER team uses
to set GW's electronic
resources subscriptions.
But our recent discovery,
and I can share with you
that our master matcher, Sherry
Chang, is in the audience,
she uses SQL to query all this
data and let us, you know,
lead us through this process.
We usually spend a
month or two looking
at that data before
we decide what to do.
So right now we are still
in an investigation process.
And so what we are doing is
that we've discovered collation
manager says we have this many
titles selected of
this many in this set.
Then we check with [inaudible]
solutions, which we have more,
then when we request the
marc records to examine
from OCLC's collation
managers, we actually got less.
So OCLC said we had 311, we
actually get only marc records, 289.
But in our local system
we already had 396.
And [inaudible] solutions
say we have 615.
So they say what do
we actually have?
So I went to the vendor,
vendor says no, you have 622.
So I, right now, we are just
pulling our hair trying to deal
with this electronic resources.
So I'm so glad that we
forgo electronic resources.
And when we first did
our recommendation,
otherwise we wouldn't be
where we are right now,
and I wouldn't be sharing
with you, so.
>> Mark Winek: I think we have
time for one more question.
Is there anyone else?
>> I wondered if you talked to
any authority vendors, Jackie,
so that we all don't have
to reinvent the wheel
and do what you're doing.
>> Jackie Shieh: You
know, interesting thing,
I think that they will
be our business.
I'm sorry.
No, one of the things that we, a
serendipitous discovery for us,
Sherry Chang found that and
I didn't even realize it.
You know when we, GW's
activities all tied in,
all of our services tied
in with our voyager.
But we are so lean, we, our records,
a lot of our records weren't touched
for the last 20 years, okay?
So a lot of our headings are so out
of date, we didn't know what to do
because we simply don't have
the manpower or we don't have
that attention span, so to speak,
to tackle this huge problem.
So I was talking to Terry Reese,
and you know, [inaudible],
which it's really interesting
I remember
when I was querying using LWP,
querying Amazon.com servers
for in copyright out of print title.
So when you query data in SQL, you
can get back not just your 100,
your authorized heading, you
could get back all the references.
So what happened is our
heading was old, so when we send
in for query it actually found in
the not the authorized heading,
but it got back the authorized
heading to our system.
So what was brought to my attention
was because we rely on a lot
of gifts, we have donor
informations,
and we have to identify
donors, main entry as donor,
and so when we're doing this second
phase of our reclamation project,
it was too hard to insert back the
field saying so and so is a donor.
Okay? So we recognize
this particular donor
and his name was different.
So how, we said to ourselves how
in the world did this happen?
We didn't make any
changes on his heading.
His name came out with a JR,
the other one was just his name
and his year, but now he's JR,
yes indeed, inserted in between.
And so we was like, let's
see what else happened here.
So that was our experience.
Now we never talked to authority
vendors because we are not
in a position to talk to, you know,
authority vendors for our process.
So a lot of this process is, you
know, we're still in testing mode.
We do not know what
the future holds.
We just know that let's give
it a go and see where we are.
And if this is total disastrous,
fortunately it was
okay with our AUL.
That was the thing.
Our AUL okay it and we, before
we actually started on July 26,
we actually froze our,
we have a snapshot
of our voyager data
cut off at July 25.
So if we broke the
system, we can rebuild it.
We have a safety net.
So fortunately, we
didn't need to do that.
>> Mark Winek: And so our final
speaker for today is Linda Wen,
who joins us from the
Washington College of Law
at American University where
she is the head of collections
and bibliographic services.
Her previous professional
experiences includes a term
as the head of IT at the
University of Arkansas, Little Rock,
she has significant research
experience in e-resources meta data,
technical services work flows
and integrated library systems.
And welcome, Linda.
>> Linda Wen: Okay, can you hear me?
Good. Okay.
Let's get started and
get it over with.
I have been quite nervous
all this morning.
And the beauty about the last
speaker is I don't have much to add.
A lot of this has already been
covered already this morning,
so I'll be fast.
Again, my name is Linda
Wen, I'm sorry about my,
on the speaker description,
I did not mention that I'm
from Washington College of
Law, American University.
Okay, we will talked
about linked data today.
Linked data is net worth
of RDF statement expressed using
published end of vocabulary,
which is usually referred
to as triple,
consists of a subject,
predicate and object.
Or, in other words,
entity, the property
and the relationship
and the property value.
And so, we have a triple statement
like a person is the author
of the work, or the work is
a genre of science fiction,
and when we talked about linked
data, we talked about the URI's
and the subject, predicate and
the object usually are resolved,
are identified by a URI and resolved
to authoritative vocabulary.
And all these entities and
triples can be interconnected
with each other.
And so every entity will have for, a
bunch of properties circled around,
and then we will have
an entity graph.
So it looks like this.
So for a computer, it doesn't know
what a Mona Lisa is, just a stream.
But with all the ID's around
property relationships around it,
this name got a, becomes a thing,
a life, so the computer's got
to know what it is about.
So the stream becomes a thing,
for the com, for the computers,
the things will have
a URI which point
to an authoritative vocabulary.
So this kind of resembles what we
librarians do as authority control,
except that the authority vocabulary
is all of, identified by URI's.
So the libraries have
been doing, been busy,
doing identifying its entities
with all the properties around
and they interlinked to each other.
So we will have for this graphs,
connected with each other.
And we will have this
ideally, all this world,
when the authoritative vocabulary
hubs connected to each other,
we will have this famous
linked data cloud.
And we can take a look.
So this is the site of this open
linked cloud, and if I click
on it, I can see the details.
And I want to take a look at the,
what the library's been doing.
We'll see the center of
the cloud is DBPedia.
And we will see some very
famous names among the library
and the publisher community.
Let's see.
I think it's better this way.
Okay, the green part,
the green section is of,
the green section consists of the
hubs contributed by the library
and publisher communities.
That takes about, let's
see, 20% of the cloud.
So that's where we are now.
And outside the library community
there are some example famous linked
data players, and, well,
Google Knowledge Card.
I do a search, To Kill a
Mockingbird, and we will see a list
on the left of the
links to the documents.
And the right hand side
is more of a graph,
or more of an entity relationship.
And the Google already answered
some of the user's questions.
And that's also tells us
about, that even Google is goes
through these coexist path.
On one side is the traditional
and on the other side is trying
to do the linked data model.
And a big player of this Google
Knowledge Graph is Wikipedia.
Okay. We will see that later.
And if I do our Wikipedia search,
we, one thing I want to point out is
that we have this link to OCLC.
I mean, link to the
OCLC record, right here.
And towards the end of
the linked data listed
that OCLC already published it.
So every OCLC record, whatever
search you do, you will,
towards the end, the linked
data and we will, at this page,
we'll see that we have this
predicate and objects listed
and some of the authoritative
hub names listed.
For example, schema.
Okay, and another example I
want to talk about is BBC.
BBC has already publishing
it's vocabulary on ontology
and also populated
all their websites.
And this played a big role
during the Olympic Games.
And so every athlete, every team,
has its own website generated
with all the dynamic games
and statistics listed.
And we can take a look at the
mapping of the ontology of the BBC.
And on the top in the prefix,
we see some of the big names
of the authoritative ontology.
And towards, in the middle, I
want to show everybody is the,
take a look at the
core concept ontology.
And there is a graph of how
the structure of the BBC site.
And on the right you see the
entities, person, place, events,
organizations and things.
Some of these overlap with what
we're talking about in the library.
So, okay, and we, this morning,
talking about that linked data
graphs, and the change the data
from like, for example,
the graph on the left is
like resemble what we have as a
record, and on the right hand,
with all the URI's, so the
record as become puzzle pieces.
The puzzle pieces can then
reconnect with other puzzle pieces
and become other websites or another
group of knowledge communities.
So that gives us a bunch
of benefits of linked data.
It's easier to get updated.
And less human errors
in dynamic updating.
And also less maybe
application cost.
I listed here some
of the early players
of the linked data vocabulary.
And if you take a look at any of the
linked data example, record example,
you'll see these links,
you'll see these names.
And this BibFrame vocabulary
is all what we know,
what are we most familiar with.
And let's take a look
at that category view,
which is more for the catalogers.
And probably you will find like
a journal title being absorbed
by another journal title, such
kind of properties in Library
of Congress BibFrame
initiative, right?
Welcome cataloger librarians
feedback.
I think, by now, probably,
everybody has seen this image.
It's talking about the,
how to prepare the data.
And is your data 5 star?
Which means is your
data out in the web?
And is your data machine
process-able?
For example, if it's an image of PDF
file, it's not machine process-able,
it's better in the CSV file.
And your data, is it
confined in your IOS rather
than with all the links
which can be queried,
but outside of the
library community?
So library and data entities,
this image is from OCLC,
so OCLC's job is focus
on the key entities
for some place organization
concept work and events.
And take a look at the data,
what we have in the library,
I think we can categorize
them into these four groups
in library authority
files, labeled names
and half structured
and unstructured text.
As I mentioned before
that with URI's,
data with URI's resulted
to vocabulary.
The process, or the concept,
resemble what we have been
doing, so authority control.
So the focus, or the center
of the easy part is the,
of all those four categories,
the authority file probably is
the concentration of our work,
because it already have these
links to authority control records.
So I would like to talk
about several examples.
So on the top inside one authority
record we are familiar with,
was the one 010 field.
This is both Library of Congress
and OCLC, being using this set
like ISBN numbers, LCCN numbers,
this already been transferred
to be URI's.
And what about the rest of this?
For example, 150 is put in the 650
Bib Record and so it has a link.
If we can, if we can apply
and identify to the 150,
then the 450's unauthorized
terms, and 550's is easier
because with the subfield of
WG, we can use the [inaudible]
or S K O S broader
property to identify those.
So this is, for the concept or
subject headings, this resembles,
we can deal with those authority
records and make them URI's.
But what about the names,
person, authority records?
I have one example
for Stephen King here.
Take a look at the bottom
in SKOS, S K O S URI.
And the first, it identifies
as a person name as concept.
And for other languages, translation
of the name, it gives a old label,
an [inaudible] also for pen names.
So in authority record,
where it says the URI,
the URI doesn't tell the
main label that the rest
of them are actually
property of the person.
So it's different from
the subject headings.
And I think OCLC has been
thinking about this, so it's trying
to use a friend of a friend standard
to deal with this kind of problems.
So at the, still at the bottom, you
see in friend of a friend standard,
a person's name is in the person
label, and then the rest of them,
including the pen name, other
version, or other language
of the name, as the properties.
Other libraries, their big
library communities have been busy
converting the library
data to linked data.
And we, let's take a look
at the British National.
Okay, so here, we list the
some examples what you can do
with the linked data.
Take a look at the sample
queries so the population
of possibilities is endless.
So if I'm interested in
the 50 other born in 1945,
or I can put my own
labels, own query codes
down here, and I will have
the result here, a list of
all others born in that year.
And because the born year
and the author's name
and all the author's
works, they all different,
they become different
identities, puzzle pieces.
So I can sample them and
package them as different result.
And one thing I want to mention
about Oslo Public Library is
that library's already dropped
marc, so if you're interested,
take a look at their catalog
and see how they're doing.
And also, you can query their data.
Whoa, we are having this com
meeting in the Library of Congress,
so we are all very
familiar with this BibFrame.
BibFrame, I've been
thinking about this BibFrame,
the BibFrame divide the records up
and so they like, so the BibFrame is
like giving you all this bucket
for the different fields.
So for the work entity,
I am thinking that these records
can belong to that bucket.
And for instances
and library holdings, last
slide, the annotations.
And all these, when these are become
divided and put in those buckets,
and all these can then also be
resigned, be assigned [inaudible]
and then linked to other entities.
I think that's the record that we
was just talking, we just talked.
And here's a little tool, that
if you want to get your feet wet,
you can compare a marc record into
the total expression of linked data.
So for,
it's quite easy to use, so just
use, need to use the Library
of Congress record number.
It's not the regular
001 record number.
So we talk about this, the tool
to compare, and also you can,
you have marc two in the
BibFrame transformation service,
marc frame editor, maybe let's
take a brief look at the editor.
Here's a demonstration site.
So you don't even have to register
and you can just play with it.
Okay, so, so say I have a copy of
some work or a copy of an instance
of a work and I can just,
this is like copy cataloging,
and if I'm looking for,
say c level rising,
it will give you a list of all
the records which already have
at the Library of Congress.
It's just not working today.
And I'm experiencing it and I would
like this left encode instead
of this keyword search.
So, let's see.
It's not working.
So when you're done you
can download the record,
take a look, so let's see.
And at the bottom of that list
is marc next, which is the,
Jackie talked about this morning.
It's the new function in marc edit.
And this look quite familiar, and I
can demonstrate it on my computer,
or I have several slides.
So if I click on that marc next,
I have this list of tools there.
I'll first talk about the testbed,
and it, I used it to test it out.
And for example, I, oops,
I was interested in how
that c level rising book, it looks
like as a, in BibFrame format,
so I download that record
and I click on this testbed,
and I can specify the
base URL as either local
or as other authoritative
ontology URL there.
And then if I press it, it
says file has been processed.
It's quite straightforward.
When I open it up I have
this marc record confirmed,
transformed to this new format.
Okay. So link identifier,
this is a very handy tool
that you can already be doing.
You can insert embed this
in the regular work flow
like Jackie talked
about this morning.
Say, also you have a
marc record and you want
to insert all the sub field zeroes
from different sources, they,
right now they have this
Library of Congress [inaudible],
and the pull down list is very
long, and I don't think every one
of them are working now, but these
four listed here are working.
So depending which one you trust.
So after I process it, the
sub field zeros inserted.
So if you also want to do
Jackie's project in your library,
you can try using the marc next,
it's quite straightforward,
just 1, 2, 3 steps.
And this is the original
field, so for the marc record,
so by comparison you see the sub
field zeroes inserted automatically.
Okay. As I said [inaudible]
I'm a learning cataloger,
so I want to get my feet
wet, half wet maybe,
so I would like to recommend one
tour, it's a very important tour.
Sebago [assumed spelling], it's
like SQL to regular database.
Sebago is to link the data.
So Sebago carries across
databases and pulls structured
or semi structured data
and has even explored data
by carrying unknown relationships
and transformed RDF data
from one vocabulary to another.
So ti has all the good
functions that,
it's like it's designed
for link data.
So this is a DBP data site.
And everybody can go
there and carry DBP data,
which is the structured
data version of Wikipedia.
You can carry whatever
triples they have there.
Maybe let's try one.
Let's see.
So I'm trying to, let's see, I
want to know Library of Congress,
all the predicates and the objects.
Of course, I'll limit to say
100, otherwise it's endless.
So let's take a look.
Oh, right here.
Okay. So when I, because Library
of Congress is in Wikipedia,
so I can carry what's
all about Library
of Congress behind the scene.
So I come here to the DBPedia
site and I put the writing a line
of code, of very simple code, and I
got 100 pieces of statement there.
And as we mentioned before,
like because all the linked data
can be recombined and packaged.
So the possibility's endless,
so you can query whatever.
And let's see.
Say, say I'm on Wikipedia and
maybe I'm interested in that.
Let's see, I can.
Copy this.
They have been using this in the
URL, that piece of information,
they have been using
that as a URI actually.
So, let me try to replace
Library of Congress and try that.
Oops. See what I get.
[Inaudible] got the
information of this,
and so for use, just to come out.
Okay, so probably instead
of you asking me questions,
I would like to ask you questions.
That's easier.
So I'll be talking, thinking about
the future descriptive practice,
or future cataloging work flow.
So it will very much different.
For example, the crowd
sourcing, because a lot we have
for these library experience
like working in the library,
we have all this expertise, and
compared to the level of cataloging
with marc, we would think how
detailed the link data will be.
So maybe take the coexisting
dual path,
maybe using the follow what
the big names or COC Library
of Congress have been doing, and
also we, as individual librarians,
we contribute to proud sourcing the
description of the most prominent,
actually, the library
resources consist
of the most prominent
creative work in the world.
See, an example is we have
New York Public Libraries.
They have this jazz,
link to jazz project,
so and crowd sourcing using
all regular people and users
and the librarians labeling
all the pieces, jazz pieces,
so that the system or
the computer can query
and it can assign URI's
to those information.
Thinking of the next day, or
future, there are more questions,
like digital or published
information,
what do we do with that?
And it's like, it's things, for
example, OCLC, we take a look
at the end of every record, there
is a category as linked data,
and you will see schema.org.
So we kind of depending
on other authoritative hub
from other communities who
is like a social contract
that how much we can trust them.
So that's about what I have to say.
Thank you.
>> Mark Winek: Thank
you, very much, Linda.
Before we start our question and
answer period, we just wanted
to note that you still have
an opportunity to vote.
We noticed that there was a
discrepancy in the number of ballots
versus the number of registrants.
So you still have an opportunity to
vote until we announce the results,
so if you need a ballot or if you
have not submitted your ballot,
please raise your hand
and someone will come
around to you and pick that up.
This isn't Chicago, so no voting
early and often, just early.
So, I'd like to open the floor
if Linda will accept
questions from the audience.
Please just raise your hand.
>> Kim Kiley: Hello, Linda.
>> Linda Wen: Hi.
>> Kim Kiley: Kim Kiley.
I'm from the Library of the
United States Supreme Court.
And I was just wondering if you
think that there are any particular,
or special challenges,
in law librarianship
when we think about linked data?
>> Linda Wen: About
law librarianship.
Very good question.
As I said, I'm a learning
cataloger and I am kind
of new in the law library.
So for the law libraries,
law libraries is a very heavy
with periodicals, with
all the, like embargo,
embargo period, and name changes.
I think that it will
be very challenging.
And also, the periodicals goes to
electronic formats more and more.
And moreso, we talking
about the ISBN,
EISBN numbers and all
the challenges.
From subject heading point of
view, I don't have much to say,
but from the, maybe from the
system or technology point of view,
I would like to say I trust
the ability of the technology.
For example, the BibFrame and
other old and ontology categories
out of there, they property or their
relationship like is author of,
resolve by, all the properties are
expanding, dramatically expanding,
and we, us librarians can
contribute our point of view
to take care of those details.
So I would like to say
I trust the technology.
>> Kim Kiley: Thank you.
>> Mark Winek: Does anyone
have any other questions?
>> Yes. You said something about
what new skills catalogers need
in the new environment, but
you only touched on Sparkles.
So can you elaborate
on the other skills?
>> Linda Wen: The reason
I listed just the one is
so that we are not all overwhelmed.
I just feel, I highly
recommend the Sparkle
because of all the
functions that Sparkle offers.
It can query the, in
triples, and across the,
across different modules.
So for other skills, I think XML,
yeah, I think that's about,
from my point of view.
Scripting language.
And at the conferences I heard
people who create applications
or tools, they all
mentioned that they want
to attract more people
creating tools.
So we are, in the library
community, we are lack of for tools,
a lack of people who
are creating tools.
For example, for example if I
go to BibFrame testbed editor,
and I want to look for the subject
headings, and I have this list
of headers, what if I want
other authoritative hubs,
I want to query the other
authoritative sources, what do I do?
Does that, that can be a project
or can be, people can create tools
and embed there so it will connect
to other communities or other group
or hubs for authoritative
vocabulary.
>> Mark Winek: Any other questions?
Thank you all, and thank
you so very much, Linda.
>> Linda Wen: Thank you.
>> Mark Winek: So thank
you very much.
And thanks to all of
our speakers today.
And now a tradition, at
the PTPL Annual Meeting,
and for her last duty on
the PTPL advisory board,
I would like to present
you with Linda Geisler,
who will present the
Historical Moment.
>> Linda Geisler: Hi.
As Mark announced, this
will be my last duty,
I guess, I perform, for a PTPL.
So we're coming to the
end of the 91st meeting
of the Potomac Technical
Processing Librarians.
I'm happy to provide just
a brief historical moment.
While I was thinking about what
to select, I did some searching
on the PTL website and I actually
found a list of all the members
that had served as a chair of PTPL,
and since we're here at the Library
of Congress today, I was
wondering well, how often
or how active have Library
of Congress staff been
in this organization.
And I was kind of pleasantly
surprised to find
that there's actually been 9 chairs
from the Library of
Congress in PTPL.
Actually, the very second chair of
PTPL was Charles Martel, which was,
I believe that was in 1924.
And many of you may know him.
He's quite well known because
he was a chief classifier.
And when the decision was
made to develop a Library
of Congress classification,
he oversaw the development
of the new system base don't he
existing million volume collection
that the Library of
Congress in 1897.
Over the years, they've
had other chairs.
1935 to 36 was Theodore Mueller.
1948 to 49 was Werner Ellinger.
Other chairs include Robert
R. Holmes, 1963 to 64.
Alice F. Toomey from 1969 to 70.
She was actually a well known
reference librarian that worked
on a World Bibliography of
Bibliographies between 1964
and 1974, I mean 1964
through 74, right?
Another Member was Arthur Lieb,
who was very active in our prints
and photograph collection.
We actually have three
that were chair,
I guess during what I would call
like our recent 30 year period.
Some of them actually still work
here at Library of Congress.
One of them is Andrew Lisowski,
who was the chair from 1985 to 86,
and he works in automation with
our [inaudible] program office.
I saw that Vera Clyburn was here
today, who was our chair in 2011,
and she's the current
chief of our U.S. Art,
Sciences and Humanities division.
And, of course, I'm the
last one for right now.
But I'm sure by showing this history
that we will probably continue
to have may of Library of
Congress's staff involved in PTPL.
As was a recurring theme
at the meeting today,
education professional
development training,
it's a very important
part for our profession.
And I just think PTPL
does a really great job
in providing an opportunity
fro all of us.
It also enables us to be involved
locally with other colleagues all
over the metropolitan area,
Maryland, D.C., and to network
with all different
types of libraries.
I mean, we have academic,
federal, state, private, public.
And I just found that it's a very
convenient way to maintain currency
and learn the changes in the field
as it relates to technical
processing.
Anyway, with that very positive
thought, I'm certainly hopeful
that Library of Congress will
continue its relationship with PTPL.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.